i want the coffee shop that's ready
please give it to me
i heard i can see your knickers and i
was like
when he said it it sounded to me like he
was saying
i say the word knickers the same way as
you do
stop you guys are really leaning into
the don't put your [ __ ] in a twist
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i am your host for today
little baby man um
and uh together with me are the other
little baby men and
the little baby man
have you seen that have you seen that
image on reddit it's just like the
little baby three of us
yeah exactly
i saw some guy making his phone
wallpaper
thanks guys
but yeah you don't you guys probably
haven't seen any like you guys probably
haven't felt any break we felt a massive
break this is six weeks
six weeks since we last recorded which
to me has felt like six months right
yeah yeah like aged one year since i saw
you guys
that's crazy
oh my god um but yeah like sir if you
didn't know me and connor went back to
the uk yeah uh for like three four weeks
and then we had two weeks of quarantine
so basically scheduling that out it
comes out to about six weeks before we
last recorded
um it has been like since we started
trash taste i didn't realize how much my
schedule relied on me going to trash
taste and just seeing the boys because
like it was weird just not seeing seeing
the both of you like every week i was so
bored during september not gonna lie
like while you guys were gone like every
tuesday i was getting ready to go i was
like oh
i don't have to honey i'm going to work
i'm going to work jk oh we have our
coffees yes oh finally oh god finally
thank you
so yeah we went back to the uk that was
fun yeah how was it that was good i mean
how long has it been like two years
right almost since you guys might have
two years yeah it's been it's been about
two years so it's been two years
basically since i've seen any of my
mates there or my parents or my family
wasn't emotional
did you guys hug it out yeah it was
weird seeing my parents really because
it was just like i've only seen them
through zoom for like two years and it
was just kind of like right right oh
yeah yeah yeah it was weird having
conversations with people not through a
discord call or the zoom call because
you realize i i've forgotten what it was
like to just actually catch up with
someone not through a computer like damn
look at those graphics
i can touch them
i felt like when i went back to wales i
felt like the pope going around a small
town i was like hi guys i'm my parents
yes give me a hug
i'll give you i'll take a picture with
you parents um
i don't know
it's uh it was nice i uh i also learned
from my past mistakes of when i used to
go back home
um i actually like try to schedule as
many hangouts with friends as possible
right i reached out to as many people as
possible yeah because
the last time i went home i just kind of
thought yeah i'll figure it out when i
get there and i ended up like not doing
anything like half the days and i was
like [ __ ] i really should have yeah i i
uh i did the same thing as you and then
i i think i i made another mistake and i
think i planned two months oh yeah then
because because then then i i kind of
realized about like five six days in
like not even like halfway through my
trip
seeing someone every day you haven't
caught up to someone for two years what
do they want to do like crack open some
beers or a bottle of wine you just like
you end up just eating and drinking like
[ __ ] every single day
and so you basically downloaded the
alcoholic dlc
basically so i was there for 20 days and
only
one day i didn't drink
jesus every single day i had at least
one beer or something just because that
was like the thing yeah so i think that
you do in the uk yeah i think seventy to
eighty percent of my schedule for my
days there were seeing someone or
catching up with someone yeah so and uh
that that meant seventy to eighty
percent of my trip was like
having some sort of drink yeah yeah yeah
do you drink with your parents yeah yeah
yeah yeah so your parents are drinking
as well right yes
my parents don't drink but since we
haven't drank anyway no no but since we
haven't drunk in two years they they
they brought open a bottle of wine and
they had a glass i was just like oh [ __ ]
okay oh it's this is a special occasion
like i think i've seen my mom drunk
before this once in my life and it was
for like my cousin's wedding yeah it's
just just the weirdest [ __ ] thing
right because my mom's like my mom is
like
as far as my perception is like the
biggest straight edge there is right she
doesn't drink she you know doesn't smoke
doesn't do anything like that i had
never ever seen her like in my life i
think i've seen her like take a sip of
alcohol about like i think five times in
my life total total um and then i
remember going to my cousin's wedding
and uh my entire family were there um
everyone had like flown in from thailand
so it was a rare occurrence that we have
a massive family gathered in one place
and it was the first time i'd seen
like a different side of my mum like i
had no idea
i had no idea that there was just this
monster playing with it
right
and
and it felt like it felt like almost
like she she got more drunk than sydney
on the day she got drunk faster than
sydney and that that gives you an
indication of like
how surprised i was right and i remember
like halfway through the wedding
um i i come sit i i i come sit down and
my mom and dad are just sitting on this
table
my mom has a glass of wine in front of
us
um
and i i don't know how much she had
drunk at this point and she was like
gig oh my name's gig it's like gig do
you want you want to see me down this
glass of wine i was like
no no no mom i don't want to see you
mom no she was like i'll do it i'll do
it i was like mom no no no don't do it
and she just
i was like mom
what are you 15 what did what are you
18.
meanwhile there's like six bottles of
wine
on the dance floor like this this is
like 10 10 11 p.m she was on the dance
floor just like you know she was she was
uh sydney was like pretty not sober but
she was like merry you know she wasn't
completely drunk and then my mom just
comes up to her takes takes the bottle
of um beer that she's drinking just
downs in front of her and takes that
gives it back to her i've never seen
sydney so dumbfounded in my life
that's awesome but yeah so so yeah
i ended up drinking with my parents a
bit more which was a very rare
occurrence so of course of course i'm
gonna share some alcohol with them but
about like the fifth day in your body's
just like please please no more like
please i just like i i i like the social
aspect but my god my body just died like
halfway through the trip i think jesus
damn yeah i don't know i i just i
there's a thing where especially in with
my family they drink quite often
so i feel like they saw it as an excuse
to drink more than usual yeah so then it
become a thing where i was like this is
great but i'm dying
my dad's retired as well now so yeah now
he he loves it he's just like yeah i i
thought my dad would get bored being
retired he seems like i thought he was
one of those guys that really needed
like a job to keep him like occupied but
yeah he [ __ ] loves it he just gardens
all day and he loves it it's like he's
like that's his life isn't it yeah he's
living in life he like bought a canoe
and i'm like oh [ __ ] like buying a canoe
who buys a canoe that's like what even
store a canoe like how do you mean keep
that i don't even know the logistics
behind owning a canoe seemed way too
difficult
yeah yes but i mean like seems like he's
uh loving it and uh yeah so it's nice it
was it was always just picked hobbies
that are going to keep him active yeah
yeah
there's other things you could he could
have invested in true yeah
he occasionally does do work he does
like helps a friend with houses building
stuff i don't know
yeah for me that's all like that's
that's i mean
that's where i want to be when i retire
yeah right
uh yeah it was it was fun i went back
and forth between wales and london it
was a lot of fun um just got to see as
many friends as possible and drink way
too much alcohol we do that's kind of i
mean like because uh we posted a few
pictures while we were on like break in
the uk but i remember like
i remember we were catching up with a
bunch of our friends and i actually
hardly ever talked to connor yeah in our
trip i mean we did we we obviously like
talked and caught up and everything but
we mostly spent time with like just
catching up with
other people need to talk to you guys
yeah yeah we see each other everywhere
we [ __ ] talk to you way too much
i feel like we had a mutual
understanding that couldn't escape you
of like we've talked every week for like
the past [ __ ] over a year now yeah we
can have a little bit time apart and i
think i think the only times that we did
do something together was uh i think we
played like a game of chess
when i was drunk we were both drunk
and uh and of course you beat me um
you're the only time when there was
unfortunately there was no one
the next chess tournament should should
have our blood alcohol level measured
before and you need to be x amount
required to play that's what we need to
disqualify if it's below 0.7 but you're
a little too sober for my liking let's
like you're not in you're right so many
brains every time you lose a piece you
got to do a shot or something i don't
know just just die yeah this this is
what chess needs the next evolution
from going from casual chess to just
absolute abhorrence
i also like playing chess again i
remember playing chess against you
because we had we had a physical board
none of this you know none of this
online chess business we're an old
school and uh
we even had like a chess clock and
everything like that and uh i think i've
realized how much i've relied on like
the chess.com ui to really like oh it's
very be good at the game because
otherwise you have to look down like
this right because because i i was
pretty interested at that point but i
remember i fell for like the most
obvious checkmate of all time oh yeah
right
and uh and like and i i was like i was
trying to question how i couldn't see
that because we bet 20 pounds on the
game
i don't know why we bet 20 pounds in the
game i think i was like drunk at the
time but uh whenever whenever i'm like
playing games with friends i'm like 10
bucks let's make it interesting let's do
it let's have fun
fair fair yeah how was how was your
perception of england going back i wrote
notes i wrote your notes your wrong name
wrote notes oh this is why you wanted
chris told me to write notes my phone is
on one percent um you're gonna read them
also what i'm gonna do i'm gonna read
through them all then we can talk about
it okay very very dirty lovely
london is really loud i didn't realize
how noisy it was before it feels like
the same amount of people are walking
around tokyo but but in london it's less
orderly yeah yeah lots more homeless
people making gestures or saying
something to you whenever you do
anything like when i this guy just
started talking to me in in the
in the lift and i was really confused
and i i just forgot that that was like a
thing that was like
he started just talking to him and i was
like i'd literally just checked into my
hotel yeah just going off the flight i
was like what do you say to you he was
just like he was talking about like um
did you say hi he's like oh hi hi how
you doing i'm like
me
it's so funny to say that cause i
literally got recommended a video like
yesterday of this satire like news
report that's just like northerner
terrorizes londoners by saying hello
literally what happened oh yeah uh
people would
people okay when they bump into you
right in japan right yeah and i've
totally forgot this is a thing this is
the longest cable on earth man
when when people bump into you in japan
they say sorry yeah so many people
bumped into me and were just [ __ ]
and didn't say something didn't say
anything i i i could not every time that
happened to me i could not stop saying
samimasen
it was just like it was just like muscle
memory even if i hadn't bumped into
someone i was like on the tube right and
i was like
i was like i was like i'm not in japan
anymore i need to stop doing this
because no one else is saying this [ __ ]
but like i just couldn't stop saying it
or like subconsciously uh i had um one
thing that happens in japan now i don't
expect this so i i just i just noticed
that it was different when you get a
taxi in japan the taxi driver will
always try and help you with your bags
even if you don't need it right yeah it
could be the smallest bag on earth and
he might try and come out and help you
with it yeah um and like never happened
with taxis in the uk i know i was every
time i had a suitcase or anything they'd
just sit in the car and then i'd have to
open the boot too as well which is fine
totally fine with that but i just
thought i was like oh yeah yeah there's
the thing that we don't do right
um and that was most of them yeah that
was that was the most i'll tell you the
biggest the the immediate thing
that uh i noticed about going back to
the uk that i immediately missed about
japan uh so i think it was the second
day that uh that we landed there
and um oh sorry my second day in the uk
we uh went out to just
walk around brighton again walk around
town uh because it's been a quite a
while since i've been in my hometown so
me and cindy just went out
did a quick shopping trip and uh i got i
got thirsty my throat was a little bit
parched right okay and so i started
searching for a drink in order to quench
my thirst right and i look around and
i'm just like
where are the vending machines
how how am i supposed to procure some
liquids so that's
so that's how they quench my thirst
right and i walk around in this shopping
center and i'm like wait and then i soon
realized i have to go to a shop yeah in
order to purchase some liquid it's not
even a convenience store like a
supermarket yeah they're like like a
corner shop yeah yeah yeah i'm just like
well what backward system is this you
know yeah i i need to go to go into a
shop that sells other things other than
drinks and uh i need to do human
interaction in order to purchase this
like what
what is this we really do take for
granted how many [ __ ] vending
machines are on this car i didn't
realize that because like sometimes i'm
just walking around i get a little
thirsty and i'm just like literally a
minute away from the next vending
machine i didn't realize how convenient
that was until i went to the uk and like
it's like it's in a big shopping center
most of this is just like clothes
or like different different kind of
stores that are not like food drink
items and even if there is most of them
are like you know something like super
drug or some some very big you know
pharmacy store where they sell they sell
drinks there but it's a it's way bigger
than it needs to be so i end up like
having to go in go into this massive
store go to like the small segments just
for food and drink and then and then
line up yeah and i'm just like
disgusting disgusting
not on my watch
but that is like the first thing i
noticed where it was just like i i
really missed vending machines and just
like being able to like buy you know
very conveniently buy a like a snack i
felt that way as well when like whenever
i go back to australia or the or like
the us or anything as well because like
we have vending machines like in
australia in the u.s yeah but you don't
have like a suica yeah right yeah so you
have to like [ __ ] reach in grab your
[ __ ] change jiggle that around and
then yeah
i don't know why they got your fired
[ __ ] vending machines in the west
because sometimes the drink doesn't even
[ __ ] yeah
that's true so i'm like oh good i'm
about to gamble three dollars to see if
i can even sometimes you get a double
pool as well
that just happens sometimes you're
really lucky
like you you buy a drink and you're like
i'm gonna buy another drink immediately
but then but then the machine is
designed in such a way that it just
can't handle two drinks being dispensed
at once so you have to like [ __ ]
scrunch your hand inside and like pull
one out yeah just so you can unblock
this [ __ ] thing yeah but i noticed as
well obviously like i i got out of the
airport and just like no one was wearing
masks really yeah yeah no one was
wearing that and that not that i you
know i don't i don't have a [ __ ]
opinion on it i do whatever i'm told to
do right i'm a sheep all right what can
i say
[Music]
that's taking a stance in the self-care
i guess i don't give a [ __ ] i'm just
like if everyone around me is wearing a
mask i'll wear a mask you know what i
mean but it was one of those things i
was like oh
whoa this is [ __ ] weird and like yeah
cause in japan it's like you know
you'll be crucified if you don't wear
them you could be in the middle of a
rice field and they'll still still find
a way to crossfire exactly and like it
was just like so strange just seeing
everything kind of back to normal it was
like the uk just took the route of we
don't give a [ __ ] anymore open back up
but was also it was but the rules are
different as well between england and
wales and because i was traveling
between them
on welsh trains you have to wear a mask
on english trains you don't have to wear
a mask but some trains go from wales to
england so what happens is is that when
you get into england people just took
off their masks on the terrain
which does nothing which then just
eliminates the whole point of you know
yeah where i was like you know i'm not
that i i
think one or one of either is wrong all
right i'm just like it
invalidates for both if you have to put
it on or off yeah yeah you're on the
same goddamn train it was yeah it was
whatever
that was that's that's like you being on
a flight and then like oh we're we're
now
[Applause]
and i was wearing a mask
and i thought this was only in like in
america but someone came up to me and
was like take off your mask
what yeah someone came up to me like
take off your mask and i was like i
don't think i will and then he was like
why he was where were you i was in wales
all right he was saying so yeah well you
have to wear master i stolen well no no
no you don't oh you just did anyway but
no right um i was like the only person
wearing a mask right yeah
i because i also i look like [ __ ] i
wanted to cover my face
i felt dreadful but he came up to me and
he was like take off your mask and i was
like no and then he was like why why are
you wearing a mask and i was like i just
ignored him i was just like i carried on
my phone and i was just like on the
train uh no no outside the train station
right you just like take off your mask
and i was like no
why i don't know some people get weirdly
offended by it
it's like sorry i'm protecting myself
yeah you know like one time i was
wearing it as well and the guy asked me
uh he was like are you wearing that for
me or for you and i was like
for me
i mean both technically because the
thing was is that even though you know
because we had a flight to get on so i
was coming up to that flight i was like
i'm wearing a mask because yeah i do not
want to get it yeah of course just be
having to rearrange all my plans and
delay transition yeah of course so
that's why i was wearing it and then i
was like oh my god i was like why are so
many people [ __ ] coming up to me and
telling me to take off my mess because
you're taking a stance and like i think
i think going back to england because i
had very similar experiences
where um every time
every time like
every time i'd meet like some group of
uh some group of friends they'd question
me of like why i chose to wear a mask
why i chose to put on this mask
autobiography
they didn't listen to me until i put on
the mask
and so like i get questioned about it
i'm just like i don't know i just i need
to fly back to japan in like two weeks
i'm pretty used to it and i just don't
want to take any risks i don't know like
this that's just my my uh
my opinion man like
it's like why do you have to be like
accused for protecting yourself
i'm not saying that's like being like
why are you wearing the condom yeah take
it off
it's like i'm going around being like
put your mask on put your mouth i don't
give a [ __ ] you don't need to if you
don't if the government tells you you
don't need to wear it i don't give a
[ __ ] don't wear it i'm just going to
wear it but the government also says
don't wear a mask yeah like it's not
like they they're you know they're gonna
[ __ ] you know take your mask away i
just feel i just feel like what i've
realized going back home at least in
england it was it became very like
political yeah like like it's it's like
as you know as as everything does but i
feel like we got sheltered from that in
japan because everyone here wears the
masks
and
everyone here wore a mask before kovid
and that's why it was like super easy to
just integrate that into society whereas
um like people just don't like being
told what to do in england
you know
america as well you know it's it's it
was it was something where just doing
this one thing like wearing a mask was
like
in the in in that environment you were
making a statement or a stance or a
choice
that was conscious i guess and i just
never really it's like what about it
that deeply i get that but it's like i
don't know why that is you know subject
to ridicule or criticism right it's like
it's not like you're doing something bad
by protecting yourself yeah i don't know
i i i it was it was weird i didn't know
it was the other way around right yeah
i mean this is
the way i looked at it was not even a
political sense i was just like i just
want to wear it because i want to wear
it [ __ ] off yeah yeah like like you're
wearing a hat would you tell me i can't
wear a hat like yeah yeah you know
like [ __ ] what are you hiding yeah
like like me before going to england i'd
never really thought about it that
deeply i i think i've thought about you
know the difference between chicken
breasts and chicken thighs more deeply
than wearing a mask you know that's you
should have just turned around the guy
being like it ain't that deep bro
i'm just wearing a mask off my back
one one positive thing that i think
changed about england though since i've
been back is uh ever since ever since
the pandemic uh a lot of a lot of big
establishments now have made it possible
for you to just order your food via qr
codes oh yeah that was yeah yeah i know
and i was like right we're getting to
the japanese way of things now yeah less
human interaction oh brilliant although
i love it i was at nando's as you go i
had i had to pause that just for
dramatic yeah yeah i was in now nose
and i was i was trying to order my meal
and i was in a kind of a rush as well
yeah so i didn't have much time and i
thought oh it'll be easier on the app
turns out like the the this uh specific
nando's restaurant just didn't have good
cell phone service
and they didn't have free wi-fi so i was
like fighting for my life trying to
order this [ __ ] thing and every
single time i got to one webpage it just
could not get to the next one and i
would it was like i had to keep
resetting
i spent about 20 minutes trying to order
this meal that i only had 10 minutes to
eat yeah and then eventually went up to
the counter and i was like give me this
and they got my [ __ ] order wrong
and it was terrible i mean it was it
didn't taste good either really the
specific nando's did not taste good and
i was like
butterfly chicken burger
you mean the chicken breast burger yeah
yeah chicken breast
[Laughter]
i had great nando's when i was done i
[ __ ] missed the chips were kind of
[ __ ] the coleslaw was not as good as i
remembered i don't know it was uh i
don't know if my tastes have changed
maybe nando's isn't just as good as
europe maybe that nando specifically i
need to try more
because i had kfc and that was fantastic
i had uk
the second biggest thing i noticed which
was i've really really missed japanese
food service you know it's yeah
so many times i'd go to restaurants and
like half the tables still had the [ __ ]
from the previous customers on it yeah
and i was like oh
yeah that just like isn't a thing in
japan like that shit's gone immediately
yeah oh yeah they won't even let you in
the restaurant i mean sometimes they'll
take the plate away while you're still
at the table yeah yeah
yeah because like i i think you know
be after after being there for like two
weeks or something you you've had like
all the food that you missed from being
in japan and after that you go back to
your usual eating routine and you're
just like man like you forget how good
japanese food is and just like japanese
restaurants in general because like you
order anything here even if it's off
ubereats or you go to a random
restaurant and it is it is just like
really good food standards and i just i
just forgotten how many british
establishments were just really really
[ __ ] mediocre right and
like after you
after like the novelty wears out of yes
i'm having all these things that i've
missed being out of being out of the uk
after that wears off you're like
damn japanese food is just better
it is just so so much better
and uh yeah i've really felt that in my
last week in the uk where i just like i
just missed having good food on the
daily i don't know do you have any
japanese food around no no i didn't have
any japanese some food some of my
friends wanted to and i looked at them
like no
they're not having japanese food it's
like the first time i ever went to la
and they took me to little token i was
like
i came from big token
episode of the simpsons when they go to
japan they go to america yeah
no no come on
yeah cause like what i didn't understand
because i just realized this is you know
the uk is also island nation like japan
but japanese japan has really spoiled me
with good seafood and just you know
fresh seafood that you can find yeah
right everywhere basically and just like
getting good seafood in the uk so
[ __ ] difficult and i don't know why
it is because we're an island nation
that is smaller than japan you know
you know our coastline should be easier
to get to why why is it so hard to find
against the traffic yeah yeah yeah why
is it so hard to find good seafood oh
that is not just like fish and chips you
know yeah yeah i did have a good lobster
actually did you yeah that was good but
how much did you pay for it you don't
want to
that's the thing right like it's
probably like if you want good food you
probably have to pay arduous amounts of
money you you do you
it was like a seafood pasta yeah and i
was really craving lobster because i was
like i didn't really get lobster in
japan and i really wanted like a creamy
did we get lobster in the uk uh yes
if you can pay for it it's quite
expensive okay
for like
not frozen canned stuff yeah and it was
really good and it was it was probably
the most i depend on a single dish in
the uk and i i was it was something
ridiculous like 30 40 or something
but man was the lobster good that was so
worth it
yeah every once in a while having like a
something like that like treating
yourself to something kind of that
expensive is very nice but yeah
definitely something i felt so guilty
for when i was looked at the bill i'm
like i literally had a pastor
i'm like filing a mortgage i'm like
holy [ __ ]
yeah i do something similar in hawaii i
had i had a fifty five dollar
possibility it was like once
in
again it was another seafood pasta i
don't know what is about seafood pasta
but like there was so it was like the
entire cast of the little mermaid on
this [ __ ] parcel like there was so
much seafood on it yeah and i was like
okay i now i can see why also 55 i'll
never do that again yeah i don't know
how australia is but i noticed that the
fancy restaurants in japan are cheaper
than the fancy restaurants in the uk oh
yeah yeah
because in japan right you can go to a
restaurant and you can you can buy a
bottle of wine and it's yeah even though
it's it's obviously more expensive that
would be buying it wholesale it's still
not that big bad like you can if we went
out together we could split a bottle of
wine and it comes to like 20 bucks each
right for like
maybe i i noticed wine in the uk was way
cheaper
someplace i went to like the the lowest
price bottle was like 150 and i was like
i want wine what kind of bougie-ass
place are you going to not even not even
like not even like that bougie places
like these were like but the wine was
bougie
i think i don't know i don't know maybe
i should [ __ ] me for trying to eat good
no because i remember like i remember
going to like tesco's and co-op to buy
like some wine and i recognized some of
the wine that was available over there
premium wines here in japan that is like
20 bucks plus they get for like a five
or seven quid and like tesco's and i'll
just but i think that's just because
japan isn't really a wine drink that's
that's exactly it and for the most part
when i noticed wines that were available
you can get wines for like a much
cheaper price because if you're drinking
wine in japan you you eating good you
know you drink you drink you drink it as
well this this is the hard part i wanted
to have the good the
the wine that was way cheaper and nice
but i also wanted to drink all the beer
so i had to like it was very hard
haven't you again you can't do both you
can't mix and match otherwise you end up
in uh you're gonna be in a coma the next
day
i had a drink the next day so i make
sure that i was in peak condition at all
times that was the biggest thing that i
i forgot about which was
tactically choosing how much you drink
so you can survive and drink the next
day as well
you can get ipas and stuff like that in
japan but like i i love like the craft
beer in the uk it's really nice i miss
having good ciders
i don't know i just missed that so i
drank a lot i had tesco meal deal as
well
how was it was it good it was amazing
i was like all of this for three pounds
get out of here he says after having his
lobster pasta yeah it goes straight to
testosterone you know i bought that
lobster pasta for like 30 to 40 dollars
i don't know how much it was and it
still didn't make me as happy as that
three pound meal deal
and it was better it was honestly a part
of it tasted better i was like oh my god
i get an innocent smoothie it's like
three pound smoothie in this three pound
meal deal they're practically giving it
away i was i was happy going back to
nando's that was like the biggest i'm
home now i i am now home
i had subway as well that was nice oh
subway i forgot i've forgotten how good
subway was outside of japan because
subway in japan if you guys don't know
you can't toast the sandwich
you can't custom you can't pick your
bread no
i mean there's like there's like it's
two choices of bread i think what the
[ __ ] is the point if you can't pick your
bread and choose to toast it like i just
i was so shocked when you couldn't toast
your sandwich in japan yeah you what
that's like the best part of any i don't
even like subway that much that's
literally the drawing point off song
yeah because i don't even like it
because we can like uber each subway
here and sometimes when these two don't
want to choose they order a subway and
i'm just like no if i'm not having my
subway toasted it is not a subway yeah i
had a lot of fast food a lot of fast
food yeah and i i'm surprised i'm not
obese by the time i came back with the
amount i drank and ate every time i saw
you in the holiday i think you had a bag
of crisps
like i went to town on christmas i think
you were like more crisp than man i was
there was like one day where like we
were hanging out and there was just like
no food in this this like airbnb
but there was like family packs of
crisps sorry like 20 packs of
i think your dinner that day was like a
hot dog and like five packs of doritos
it wasn't five yeah it was like eight it
was like
it was okay
people kill me
i almost said chips as well which is why
i like i pause i was like wait that's
not sorry i'm i'm used to saying it for
the americans yeah the chips the
americans watching but yeah no it was
fun i i had a great time i got to see
all the friends i wanted to see and yeah
that's good yeah a lot of things really
worked out nicely because i was asking
people like last minute to hang out and
luckily everyone was able to yeah yeah i
think like i had enough rest days in
there well towards the end because
michael my body was just like i i i need
to like not touch alcohol for like a
month after this and which is great
because we've had quarantine since then
um
and uh yeah tell us about the the hotel
experience so that's what i want to know
okay no no
this this experience doesn't start from
the hotel it starts from the point where
we get off the plane it starts before
that it start before we've left the
[ __ ] country it's already oh yeah
that's already
me and connor had two very different
experiences
uh leaving the country and getting back
in the country yeah so i mean how should
we do this how do we split this up so we
just i have to go by section by section
okay so first of all the most annoying
part
which is uh
to get even on the plane you need a
negative covert test form now okay i am
making a video about my quarantine hotel
thing so there'll be in-depth stuff
about that if you're interested by the
way but but i'll give you the i i want
to talk more about it because i didn't
want to bog down that video we're just
complaining for nine hours so we're
gonna complain
so so this whole thing is like confusing
right so
normally if you want a negative test
most test providers would give you a
form say hey you're negative take this
and then everyone will accept it
normally problem is japan doesn't work
like that japan trend just decided we
gotta do things a little bit different
we're doing it our way yeah it turns
like how about it's literally our way or
the highway yeah right it's like how
about we just give you a form that you
need to fill out the very specific way
that we want it filled out and this just
sends fear down anyone who knows japan
because you know they're not playing
games yeah i have heard that
some some airlines will let you on with
the negative test and you don't need
that one but why would you risk it so
i was [ __ ] myself because i was like
how the [ __ ] do i fill out this form so
this form uh needs to be signed and
stamped by a doctor it can't be it can't
be a nurse it has to be a doctor the
test can be administered by a nurse but
has to be signed and stamped by a doctor
right right
so but most testing facilities don't
have a doctor who's going to stamp or
sign it for you so then now you have to
find a place that has a doctor that will
stamp it turns out like none of these
test centers have doctors that are
willing to sign or stamp things for you
right yeah so manage to find
i found after i basically i
i went to the uk government website and
got the email of every single test
provider they recognized and sent out a
mess email to all of them this was a big
mistake because then what ended up
happening was it was one thread
and it was it was
replying to each other no no no no no no
no it was a blind carbon copy so they
weren't each other but for me it was one
thread so i i sent this email off and
within about 10 minutes i realized the
mistake that i'd made because i had 15
replies in one thread and i couldn't
keep track you basically opened a forum
post yeah i basically opened a forum
post
directly to the person and so i got like
50 responses in the first day of you'll
be like this is okay but then some of
them were like yes this is totally fine
but they didn't
like say yes to everything so so they i
had to then call up places that said yes
and i walked them through it i was like
are you sure this is okay and and one of
them was like yeah that's no problem
we've done it all the time that's
totally we've had people go to japan all
the time from our facility and i'm like
great okay so i booked on with them 150
pounds right it's like 200 right yeah
damn all right so but
i know japan i i i know that i should i
should have a backup just in case
because
i don't [ __ ] trust like that this is
i should cause you have to get it 72
hours before so if i [ __ ] this up uh i'm
i'm panicking to try and find something
so i booked two yeah i booked another
test but
i this this place said book a test with
us and then when you get your results
three hours later take those results and
book a doctor appointment and then get
the doctor to sign and stamp it all
jesus so i did that too yeah so i had
that first so i went to this testing
facility at 8 am i they shoved a thing
up my nose i'm dying
and then i get my results at 11am yeah
and it's negative and i'm like great
great so then i go to the doctor and
perfect they they sign it all they stamp
it all it was all super easy but i had
to pay individually for both those
things so it's like 150 pounds for the
test again right or no 90 for that one
and then 90 for the doctor's appointment
jesus so this is already like 400 500
bucks yeah just on the test yeah um i'm
not not counting the amount you have to
pay for the test to get in the country
as well
you have to pay for like
like you have to like a lot of things
people don't consider is like i spend a
lot we both spend a lot on just tests oh
yes so many tests because because you've
got to obviously get tested before you
fly out of japan to the uk and then you
have to get 150 bucks which it was not
150 bucks and then you have to pay for
another test when you land in the uk as
well which is also about 100 bucks yeah
lots of tests so many goddamn tests yeah
like if you're thinking traveling is
just you just have to consider the cost
of the airline that's not a thing
anymore which are also there they've
increased the prices on the flights that
they know people are flying so like the
direct flight from japan to london it
was very expensive compared to what it
normally would be
um well you also looked very i did also
book very like but even then it was
still more expensive normally um
and so yeah so i got this paper and i
was like great i have this this japanese
document signed the way i think i sent a
message to rayna scully who'd also done
traveling abroad and i was like i sent
her a picture of the signed document i'm
like does this look okay and she's like
it looks great and i'm like okay good
but i had the next appointment the next
day for the people who are like yeah
dude it's all okay and i should get it
i'll get it signed there and all that
but to me it didn't make sense a little
bit because they i was like how are you
gonna sign all this stuff
when i have to wait three hours for the
results yeah right so i turn up to this
this test the next day because i'd
already paid for it so i was like
[ __ ] i mean i'll get another test why
not let me know um i
i go there and i'm like okay so you need
to fill up this formula like no
what do you mean like no we don't fill
out that form i'm like would you
i called you up and you said that you
could fill out this form and they're
like no no no we don't do that we will
give you a form i'm like
yeah but you that's that's not that's
not good enough for japan i told you i
told you this yeah on the phone call and
you said it was no problem and they were
like no we're not doing that did you not
read the forum yeah
and then yeah
the thread and so then a woman a woman
came out of the office and she was like
oh no no no come on you're going to go
to japan she's like oh yeah come with me
come to me
yeah
and so i go there and i'm like all right
so can you fill this out no no i'm not
gonna fill it out and i'm like wow why
aren't you gonna fill it out she's like
oh because the form i'm gonna give you
is gonna be enough anyway it's gonna
have your passport information on it and
i'm like
i'm like all right
but i already knowing that i had
the signed document put me at ease i
probably would have been very
uncomfortable if i was in that situation
yeah and didn't have a backup and i'm
glad i didn't because i got my test
results after you know filling out this
form and doing
they they were like we promise it'll be
fine we promise this form will be enough
right yeah and so i'm like okay fine all
right fine so i get my results back
later it's got even less information on
it and no stamp no doctor signature than
like the other test result i got to take
to the doctor which wasn't even the real
one right so they've given me this piece
of [ __ ] form and then i went to the
website i should have done this before
like and the reviews were like terrible
for this clinic
and then i found out it was a clinic but
it was like a weird modern
medicine-esque clinic
and
but but it was a legitimate covert
testing they they were laughing right
right
not for official documents i'm guessing
yeah so then i was like all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna see
because now i have two forms yeah when i
when i go to the airport i'm like i'm
gonna give them the [ __ ] one first and
see if they accept it yeah and they
probably thought i was [ __ ] weird for
doing this as well so i give them the
form and then they look really confused
they looked really uncomfortable and
they brought like some staff over and i
knew they were about to tell me like you
can't get on the flight with this yeah
and i was like and before they said
anything to me i was like by the way i
have another form just in case and they
looked at me like what would you mean oh
i have like another test with the form
filled out and they looked at me like
i'm like i was doing something really
bizarre i imagine it would be they were
like why didn't you just give us it was
like why did this guy do like a bait and
switch because if i paid 150 bucks for
this i wanted to make sure that it was
[ __ ]
this man limit testing the system right
now
i wanted to see it's all right here's
the full patch
i wanted to see if i had been ripped off
and i i realized now i played paper
please the other day and i feel like oh
this is what they did in paper please
some people just wouldn't give their
passport or something
but yeah um
so um
testing for bugs
they didn't tell me they weren't gonna
accept it but yeah
they were like bringing managers over
and stuff after i had them this form and
i was like
don't let's let's not worry let's not
kick me out here's the real one here's
the real yeah
yeah because like i i talked to like a
few people who had traveled to the home
country and back to japan before i even
flew and that's how i knew about this
quarantine hotel that we were going to
have to stay in yeah we'll get to that
but uh they every one of them told me
you need to get this form this form that
the japanese government give you signed
doesn't matter what any clinic says
doesn't matter
what they promise if you don't have this
form you're not gonna get you're not
gonna guaranteed to get back in right
right and so you have to look for a
specific clinic that can fill out this
exact form with a doctor
which is a lot harder to find than you
originally think it is right it's really
difficult yeah it's there's there's a
big difference between getting a
positive covert test which is all you
need to get out of japan but getting
back into japan you need to have this
exact form in order to get back in japan
um and luckily connor kind of went a few
days before me so
i i had like my own clinic booked and
hearing about his second experience i'm
just like yeah i'm just gonna go for the
proven way and uh yeah let connor be my
uh beta tester yeah
it was just like it was so stressful i
was just trying to like
just trying to get a goddamn piece of
paper signed yeah and it was like
impossible
but you know luckily i managed to do it
i don't know how it would be in the us
um i just know that getting doctor
appointments in the uk is quite
difficult unless you're spending money
like a lot of money um so and again it's
kind of come under a lot of criticism
rightfully so because traveling even
though it you know obviously it's a
luxury in general but like they've made
it ridiculously expensive to travel like
like yeah like we i've already spent
like 600 500 bucks on covert tests alone
yeah same thing which i you know i'm i'm
lucky enough to afford that but like
it's pretty [ __ ] that it's that much
yeah you know i mean like and it's yeah
it's it's weird it's it's annoying so
then yeah i got on the plane and then i
almost felt too easy because i got
through checking and it was super easy
like was it easy for you as well yeah it
was very easy show them the paper they
were like yeah have have fun
yeah once once you get once you show the
paper which was the same for me like
going out the country once you show the
paper and everything's accepted then
it's like it's it's the most stressless
experience i've had in an airport
because it's [ __ ] empty because no
one's traveling so you're like
[Applause]
security or anything you just walk
straight in
um and it's just it's just a breeze i've
never had like after everything got
accepted i've never had a
more pleasant experience in an airport
and i never i never thought you could
have a good experience in an airport
until until like until now
it was really chill yeah i had a great
time at the airport it was i charge all
my devices i was like there was in my
terminal i think i counted there was
like 20 people in the whole waiting area
wow it's like the the whole thing yeah
yeah so you had like you know your whole
section to yourself it was really nice
pretty good yeah but then uh but then it
came to coming back into japan and we
always obviously talked about the
documents
um
that was just the start of the process
right because you get off the plane and
obviously you have to present the same
documents and everything like that
um and they put you they put you into
this like this queue of just checkpoints
and there's like eight checkpoints
that's before immigration
[ __ ] out so yeah eight checkpoints
before you can even get to what is
normally the annoying part yeah yeah
yeah and i
you kind of like you you go in and you
give you they present you these
documents right and then they give you a
[ __ ] tag right that you have to put
over your hand
to identify you
that's exactly it so you're literally
like being cattle being herded through
it's how it's how they know you're going
to the quarantine hotel they put this
large
thing on your hands yeah like this
they literally they literally tag you
right i'm like
and i took it off for a second and
someone shouted at me because i wanted
to get my coat off and i took it off and
they were like like two men came over
like shouting and like panicking at me
and pointing at us put it back on and i
was like what the [ __ ] man like give me
a [ __ ] second
yeah so like you have to they give you
about like 17 million documents that
they will just like check a call like
across like this journey that you take
because and and the thing is like you
present this document they check it
great go to the next checkpoint they ask
for the same document
and they check it you go to the next
point and for some reason like this
these few documents that you you have
get checked
a total about like five times
like by by different checkpoints even
though nothing changed between you
walking from point a to point b right
there's like eight stops right so the
first stop is they
so this is also a thing right no one
told me this you have to keep your
boarding card
normally on airplanes i just like
[ __ ] the moment i'm on the plane i
just like put the boarding card in my
pocket scrambled up or something yeah
but that's really because you don't need
it anymore you're on the plane you do
you the luggage the luggage tags what'd
you do with the luggage tags because
that's normally on your card oh no they
normally put that on your passport or
something oh really oh yeah but the
luggage tags i know i know my bag i've
never had to use it i i always hold on
to it until i'm out at the airport oh
the luggage tags i keep but normally the
boarding card i would like to scramble
in my pocket or something oh really tell
me no one told me you needed it because
you never need it at an airport right i
just hold on to it just in case yeah
just in case you can't throw it away i'm
not like on the plane [ __ ] tearing it
up but like yeah i don't think about it
much i kind of just yeah whatever but
yeah you needed it so when you get off
the plane they ask for like your
passport your boarding pass and the
documents now i printed off all the
documents that the japanese government
told me to have yep turns out that some
of them they just give you on the plane
anyway yep so i didn't need to print
them out so i did i didn't even end up
using my version i used the ones that
they printed out for me right uh because
it was like smaller and the one i
printed out was a4 and it was like a we
i yeah i didn't understand so so you
have these two documents one of them is
a declaration saying that you're a good
boy and you won't leave your house and
you won't break quarantine rules and if
you do they'll deport you okay um and if
you're not ominous at all yeah and if
you're a japanese national i think they
will do criminal charges or something
yeah i don't know how much they're
enforcing it um and another one was uh
you have to circle the countries you
came from you've been in the past 14
days yeah and then you sign your name
and stuff and then they always check
this and they put like they put a lot of
your information on the sheet i didn't
realize which sheet was going to be
important yeah so i didn't i didn't
either so yeah the first check is they
check those documents and the next one
is the wellness wellness check where
they take your temperature and then you
have to do a cover test immediately at
the airport okay so you use like a pcr
test not like an antigen test as well so
the difference between a pcr test is you
have to like take your spit yeah whereas
with an antigen test i think you can
shove the thing in your nose
and it's like it's like an instant
almost an instant like response with the
antigen test with the pcr it takes like
an hour you need a centrifuge for it so
yeah
the other way around the pcr test is the
one up your nose i think the antigen
test
no i i i think you can i'm i mean i took
bikes
all i know is that they put it in a
centrifuge that's yeah yeah yeah like
that's that's how they tested it
i think that's why they can do it fast
but
so you you get like asked oh you're
feeling okay uh you know they check your
temperature again i don't know what
happens if you have a high temperature i
assume they just like put you down like
they just like shoot you on the spot i
don't know like i don't
grab the pillow
like like
come out and just take you away like i i
don't know what happened
nobody so you get melted into
yeah yeah like if you anytime i asked
anyone questions i got like looked at
like a [ __ ] weirdo why is this cow
talking
okay before we go on to uh i'll explain
more of the flow i don't know okay i'll
do it after so um you go to the wellness
check and then you need to do a cover
test immediately the problem is right i
was really dehydrated and i need to
start spinning yeah yeah and i couldn't
spit anything i was just spitting air
like
and on the wall they had pictures of
plums and lemons to help you
to help you to help you get some saliva
and i'm like this is not helping
why did they not just give you a plumber
no because you're not meant to like eat
or drink anything before you do it
because that all dilutes like a result
um
yeah you do that you someone takes your
test you know they all look at you like
you're the devil
like like but the thing is the thing is
like you're you're in a room right where
uh you're just full of a bunch of people
spitting yeah it's really [ __ ] weird
and they like spitting into this
container which is like which is pieces
of plums
yeah which is like which is like you
know you don't really it's not really
like the nicest thing to watch people
spitting into this glass
this container right and sydney had like
sydney after being on his flight for
like 12 hours felt a bit queasy yeah you
know and i could just i could just hear
her in like the uh in the container next
to me because she was feeling queasy
before she had to do it and her seeing
people spitting around
she was just like
because like
because yeah he does he does you do feel
a bit sick see that's just yeah a
stranger spit just be like
it's like
[ __ ] weird and uh that sounds so
post-apocalyptic yeah yeah
you do the spitting thing you give it to
someone uh they check the documents that
you have the the right uh covid barcode
on your thing and then you go to a place
where they make you give your email and
then they they send you an email and
they make sure you got it right and
that's okay that's fine and then they
make you install these apps i i
pre-installed them but then i had a
problem this app was so [ __ ] jank
when i selected my birth date as july it
would randomly just go back to june oh
yeah yeah that's something that happened
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i had to
reinstall the whole app and the internet
was [ __ ] and it wasn't installing for
some reason and they came over and they
were like oh here's a pocket wi-fi i'm
like no i've got 4g it's fine i don't
know this app is just dog [ __ ] i don't
know going on it like didn't install and
that it's this really [ __ ] weird
thing that's watching you fill out this
this app as well and i'm just like
sorry it's all right man you can you can
help someone else i'm all right i can do
this i can apparently the first time but
i can fill it out yeah and they make you
make sure that your google maps thing is
on and i was like yeah it's on already
it's always on there like can we check
and i'm like all right sure so i showed
them they're like okay good good nice
nice nice good
yeah and then once i got that installed
you go to the waiting area to get your
covert test results
which takes a couple of hours right no
no no mine took 30 minutes how long did
yours take um
waiting mine took about an hour okay
yeah mine's about 30 minutes but then i
and then you get get put into the bus
waiting area mm-hmm yeah and that was a
long time i waited to be shipped off to
the butchers basically basically and
they've gotten it's weird because
they've got they've
laid you out like you're sitting on a
bus yeah do they do that for you as well
yeah they're in a corner and you're all
sitting like you are on a bus it's like
it's like a dress rehearsal it's like
you're on a bus
it's like what they do in school
that's exactly where where like you have
like this teacher who leads you onto the
bus and you have to sit in like the
exact same way you sat down and i'm just
like what is this
yeah and and then you know once you've
got all that then okay so this whole
process this part took like three hours
yeah and then you can go through
immigration right which which takes a
while again yeah but luckily because
there's no uh no um people traveling
it's a little quicker yeah um but yeah
it does just take yourself yes so you're
if you if you fly back in japan at the
moment uh regardless of how quickly or
how many people are like flying in with
you you're going to be in the airport
for around three to four hours i was
there for five before you get to
immigration
um
before you can even get your bags
because i was i was there wondering am i
even gonna get gonna get my bags today
yeah like what's happening with that so
yeah so you're basically after your 12
hour journey which is what we had 12 13
hours on a plane you have to draw
another four hours in an airport being
herded
um through this through the system which
like it kind of felt like this dystopian
society yeah
where you were just treated like cattle
like a piece of meat being hurted
through herded through uh you you you
know you were there to be processed
which is weird man because i don't know
what happens if you just don't follow
along yeah it was just really weird and
uh very strange you are you are treated
almost like uh a disease rather than a
person yeah yeah um which you know i i
don't give a [ __ ] about it's whatever
but it's just weird um waiting for my
bags to take so long because you have to
because obviously when you get your bags
in the airport you can just go yeah
because we're all on the same bus i'm
all dirty travelers uh we have to all
wait till everybody's gone through and
everybody's got their bag and then you
can start going through the bag checking
yeah so you still you kind of once
you've got your bag you still gotta wait
and then i don't know if this happened
to you they bring out like search dogs
and stuff yeah and they checked
everything
i was like oh my bro i'm i don't think
the dog can smell covered can it like
what what is this i'm like this is a
joke and they like they were like i
didn't like interrogate you about what
you brought in no they were asking me
like do you have any food and i was like
i mean i got like i got some snacks and
they're like what what's what is it what
is it with snacks and i'm like it's like
a nature bar and they're like does it
contain meat i'm like no it's a [ __ ]
nature bar i don't know like it was just
weird they were like grilling me about
like these cereal bars i had and i was
like it's a [ __ ] cereal bar what do
you mean look at it it sounds like
typical australian customs yeah
yeah i mean illustrate yeah it makes
sense right um and yeah we finally got
through it and i was talking to this old
japanese man because he lived in the uk
for like 20 years and he was like he was
just so funny he was just like i miss
pub already i like i miss my friends i
have good friends in pub and i'm like
yeah man i love the pub too yeah and i
was like why are you going to he's like
i'm going to um kyushu i'm like going to
accuse you what the [ __ ] what because
you can't how can you get to kyushu yeah
so he was quarantining in tokyo for two
weeks and going to kyushu i was like
[ __ ] that jesus [ __ ] you know yeah
this poor guy was like 70 and
because this guy was a seven year old
japanese man they didn't even try and
make him wear a mask like he just took
it off and no one told him to put it on
but anyone else who even took it off
they stopped and they were like put your
mess back on what are you [ __ ]
playing squid game all of a sudden like
this
literally like oh
yeah we were just chatting the whole
time but i i was like bro i think you
should put your i told him i thought i
think you should put your mascot he's
like they won't make me put it on
he's like i'm too old they won't make me
do it and to be fair
i was really impressed he was he was
that kind of amazing old man that just
did not give a [ __ ] anymore yeah he's
like i'm far too old to give [ __ ] about
your rules yeah which i respect but also
i was like bro they've got guns man put
the mask on it's literally squid game
they have guns bro put them
i'm trying to help him out here
my god and we are we got through of
course this old man they didn't make him
[ __ ] open his bag or do anything yeah
and i'm next up they make me [ __ ]
open my bag and i've got like three bags
and i'm like ah for [ __ ] sake he's
like do you smoke cigarettes and i'm
like no and he's like what about tobacco
and i'm like no
and then he's like do you have any i'm
like no i just said no what can i have
something
right
i just want to hit man
after that after you finally get through
all that i'm assuming this is the same
for you yeah you get on the bus we had
to wait 30 minutes for it to [ __ ] go
yeah and then because it was peak
traffic hours at this point it took an
hour and a half to get to the [ __ ]
hotel
so not fun but where was your hotel uh i
can't remember where my hotel was but it
was a different blindfolded me in the
box
honestly i got i got in the bus and i
just like [ __ ] conked out
i could yeah yeah it was like squid
gaming because you know music
you know they they didn't they didn't
need to gasp me i [ __ ] like
congratulations you're here on
quarantine day one yeah they took us
only half of you will survive
they took us all the way from haneda
airport which is like very south of
tokyo yeah to ryogoku
it's like it's like an hour and a half
away it was like north north tokyo yeah
and i've never been to goku before and
it was literally we were staying right
on top of the sumo stadium yeah yeah
yeah um okay mine was like 20 minutes
away from the airport [ __ ]
and so yeah we'll get we'll get into how
[ __ ] good your treatment was gone and
uh so i get to this hotel and i [ __ ] you
not there is like 40 armed guards at
this hotel for like 20 of us it was
ridiculous
it was literally like 40 armed guards
and like all they did is just watch you
just get off this bus right and they
they are watching you the whole time but
again presumably i don't know why like
this seems excessive
i don't even think the prison system has
that many [ __ ] no no
these hotels have been completely
converted into covid uh hotels right
they're close to public and only there's
one right in shinjuku sanchome right i
walked past it and i saw all the guards
and with all the facebooks yeah and um
yeah and it was just weird you had to
wait
again you have to wait for [ __ ] sake
to wait another 30 minutes finally you
get to a table where a woman talks to
you and uh she was explaining what you
couldn't couldn't do but her english was
really bad and obviously again actually
i know this is my fault i don't speak
japanese uh but i i was like um i asked
her a question and she just got really
like
what she like didn't understand and i
was like oh um maybe i can ask someone
else and i felt really bad but then
someone else came over who spoke like
perfect english and i was like right so
come on what's going on what am i doing
here man and also this whole time during
this whole thing i kept asking everyone
at every single checkpoint do you know
how many days i'm spending in this hotel
because they said three days right when
does three days start when would you
think it would start like the moment you
get to the hotel right now right that's
day zero let's stay there but
here's the thing that's orientation
at every single checkpoint i asked
people which day does it start
and everyone said a different thing so i
didn't know and how long i'm staying in
this hotel for until the like at that
thing where she says hey you can you
will get a test on this day and then if
it's negative you can leave that is when
i found out how long i'm staying in this
hotel for yeah and uh yeah so if you get
an extra test you can leave but yeah it
was [ __ ] oh my god it's [ __ ]
terrible just getting there not even to
mention the hotel oh my god yeah because
what was your room like
so it's a nice room and like apple
hotels although you stayed in the apple
hotel room yeah did you not i didn't
stay in apple hotels
hotel is a chain of uh business hotels
yeah also very famous for having a very
funny book in them have you heard of
this book
what it's a it's um a revisionist book
of japanese history
um
that is uh quite
uh what's the word racist that's the
word that's right
it's it's like it was a really famous
book and it caused a lot of controversy
before the olympics like the chinese
team refused to stay in the hotel
because of this oh yeah i heard about
that because this book is like it would
say that like things that japan did
never happened and stuff like that right
so it was a very it's kind of a somewhat
weird controversial and the owner is a
controversial figure of apple hotel i
think as well anyway stay in a just a
fun little history um so this hotel i
had one of the rooms and it's just
like it's a business hotel so you're not
supposed to like be in there all day the
idea is that you go you travel to like
somewhere in japan you do your business
in the the day and then you sleep at
night it's just used to sharing yeah
because i've got everything i've stayed
in the app hotel as well um probably
like they're all very similar styles
yeah extra i remember like there's only
enough space in there for a bed yeah
yeah and like and like there's no room
to walk at all it is very much like a
prison cell yeah because you do have a
tv right but the tv's right like you you
can probably kick the tv with how close
it is to the bed because it's it's like
it has like enough space to contain a
human being in it right and that's what
it's designed yeah so i'm 5 10 and my
feet were just at the end of the bed
yeah so if you're like six five yeah
yeah bro you're [ __ ] yeah
um
i i show it off in the video a lot that
i filmed but the
you get this room
and there's about um two steps
horizontally and like two steps vertical
of walking room
so that's all the room you have you're
not allowed to leave the room obviously
yeah um and if you do try and leave the
room there is an armed guard outside who
will shout at you if you even open your
door for long longer than like five
seconds uh because i spoke to an irish
guy who was there and he said he wanted
to get some fresh air in his room
because you can't open the window you
can't even crack it open all right like
the window doesn't open at all yeah so
if you want any fresh air like you you
can't yeah so it's kind of
at least by the second day my room
started to smell
not good
so i understand that he wanted to leave
his door open apparently like two guards
came over and like told them to close
the door and if you do it again they'll
like do something
and then we never saw him again
but all right and now so you spent three
days there right if you get a negative
test you get to leave yeah all right the
scary thing was is the moment i landed
and i got into my hotel i got an email
from the ministry of health telling me
that somebody on my flight tested
positive for kovid oh [ __ ]
so if i got kovit i would have to stay
in that hotel for 14 days [ __ ] so that i
don't know when they change your sheets
or do anything like that so they don't
change your shoes right right but like i
was like accumulating a lot of trash i
mean like meals and stuff adds up and
the bottles and stuff adds up can you
get rid of that no i only the meal they
they didn't collect bottles or they they
took yours
we'll get into that we'll get into that
and like
okay the room itself is nice like it's a
good hotel except the pillow the pillow
oh my [ __ ] god this this pillow this
pillow is meant as for sadists it's one
of those concaved like medical pillows
yeah so your neck is like this
right because it's supposed to like
stretch your neck out yeah that is not a
i do not want to sleep on that when i
have jet lag and i'm trying to just
fight for my life to get eight hours of
sleep here and so i told gone i was like
bring her to paint your own pillow
because these pillows suck but you
didn't have a hotel so yeah you didn't
need it but yeah definitely the worst
thing was not being able to walk or have
fresh air yeah and i thought
okay at least even even in prison they
get one hour of outside time a day right
yeah can i come out can i have one hour
of outside time please i want some some
walking but it's only three days so it's
not matter yeah it's it was [ __ ] but it
had to be done right and then the meals
were crap right yeah so you guys sent me
pictures of them oh yeah i got i i
posted one of them and i was like this
is the saddest breakfast ever and it
caused like a [ __ ]
argument
i don't eat breakfast or something i
don't eat breakfast right and uh this
this breakfast right had like french
fries uh sliced ham which is fine but
hot like
those uh single cheese slices sliced in
half one small tomato one piece of
broccoli a quiche or an omelet i still
didn't know what it was um
i really really hard croissant bread
roll and cinnamon roll and three pieces
of macaroni
for breakfast i think in-flight meals
are better than that well that's the
thing is that people are like this looks
amazing i'm like think about it this is
breakfast i just want like cornflakes or
something i don't want i don't want this
[ __ ] what is this i don't want cold
french fries that's another thing all of
this stuff was very cold all the meals
you get are cool it's cold and they uh
you don't have a microwave yeah there's
no way to heat it up yeah it would have
been nice of a microwave so i can heat
them up because some of them were nice
there was one where they made like jerk
chicken rice and that was good but most
of them were really ice cold
not that good um but that that that one
breakfast oh my god that made me like so
depressed i was like this
this is it and everyone's if your
situation isn't already depressing and
everyone was like it's so privileged con
it's like look at it this is not a
balanced breakfast in any capacity no
one should have cold french fries for
breakfast i was like what's wrong with
you guys because they were like in my
country that would be amazing i'm like
what country tell me your country may
have made mainland like sweating now
every because if they're like you know
whenever i've been to countries that are
you know are not as as wealthy as other
countries they normally have the best
breakfasts yeah because they're always
home cooked and they're amazing they're
like really cheap really filling like
you know i had like sri lankan breakfast
that [ __ ] was the best [ __ ] i'd ever had
for breakfast it was like a curry thing
i would kill for that over some shitty
corn flakes or oatmeal are you kidding
me yeah i got so annoyed about this
whole thing and everyone would call me
privilege but it sounds like god had a
much better time i okay so so like so
like i was prepared i was prepared for
prison i was like because i i i talked
to other people who traveled before and
had a very very similar experience to
connor um where it was it did feel like
you were like just stuck in a prison
cage and you can leave your room um
i i knew about the cold meals as well
and like the one advice everyone gave me
before traveling was
pack snacks yeah i brought a lot of
snacks
right so
like because like i i'd seen the meals
so i'll just like
all i knew is that most places had a
kettle so i was like all right i know
what i'm gonna do
i filled up an entire carry-on case
we've just it was just instant ramen
right
i posted a picture on like twitter
why did you need 20.
because me okay so like before flying
off
um i tell my mom mom i'm probably gonna
need snacks
if anyone knows asian mums they will
over pack the food for [ __ ] and she's
gonna be like okay here's what you need
for the quarantine maybe you might need
a bit more if you're missing home and
you want a bit more ramen but you know
what you know i've got a few spare why
don't i pack that as well and i'm in the
suitcase and i just see a [ __ ]
mountain of instant ramen there
and i'm just like i can survive nuclear
winter now man i'm [ __ ] sorted like
let let alone for quarantine yeah like
yeah so i had like just a whole like i
had like like a normal suitcase and then
just i carry on that was just full of
food and snacks prepared for this prison
experience i was going to get i was
going to go through um and so you know i
had exactly the same experience with
connor going on the bus and everything
calmed down the bus and woke up don't
know where i was just like [ __ ] like
like [ __ ] squid game like
where am i oh my god okay i'm ready i'm
i'm i'm ready for
i'm ready to for the prison experience
to start so i get off
and uh first thing is that you know uh
you get chauffeured in i didn't have any
armed guards just like a bunch of like
the people who worked at the hotel who
were obviously like dexter there was no
security there was security but they
weren't armed they were just people who
it looked like they were just people who
worked in the hotel just like with a
full like hazmat suit on basically oh
yeah that's totally different okay so so
um so here's a hack if uh
here's a life hack that i i learned
going through this process is if you're
if you're traveling with someone they
will give you extra privileges and extra
rooms yeah because because connor
traveled by himself i did and i was
traveling with sydney so
uh when they sat us down and uh
gave us gave us the whole spiel of love
oh you can't do this you can't drink
alcohol you go you can't leave your room
can't open your window yada yada um and
then i was just like oh i mean me and
sydney are together can we get a bigger
room please because my god like your
room contained a double bed but i
wouldn't know it was a semi double a
semi dump semi double
there is no way i could stay with
another person in that room so me and
sydney were deciding should we just you
know say we're separate in case we can
you know in case they do put us in the
same room um but i'm just like let's
let's see what they say we say we're
together and so i said oh i'm with
sydney can we uh stay together please
and they were like okay we'll we'll see
what we can do and uh so they go off
they go off they talk to like their
supervisor or something they come back
and then they tell us oh yeah i think we
can get you a uh we can we we can get
your room uh suited for two people and i
like that at this point the suite is
open at this point i didn't know what it
meant right so i i'm like doubling down
to be like um is this room big enough
for two people because
uh like if it is not big enough for two
people to stay in for possibly two weeks
if we test positive for covid you know
god forbid but if it is not big enough
then we would rather have separate rooms
yeah and then they go off they go off
they'll like
chat chatting again uh to the supervisor
and then they come back and they'll go
they get they they go
yeah i'm i'm really sorry and i'm like
okay maybe we do need to get two rooms
and we're like yeah i'm really sorry
all the king-sized beds are gone this
one only has a queen-size bed
and i'm like
can you say that again and they were
like yeah unfortunately all the
king-size sweets are gone so we're gonna
have to put you in the queen
i'm sorry the room only has three
jacuzzis the queen-size suite are you
okay with that and i'm like
yes i like to look at the city are you
okay with that and see like i think
that's good i think that's good
i'm sorry i'm sorry
and so uh we get we get taken to our
room did anyone like take you to your
room no okay we had like a guard behind
us okay so it's like smacked your ass
he's like don't look behind or you die
so we we we had like we had like we had
like four luggages with us uh like two
two big luggages and two carry-ons and
so we've been lugging them around the
[ __ ] airports and it's like heavy as
[ __ ] right and so uh after after they
check us in to our rooms uh we go pick
up they give us our meal right away
there's there's a table with all our
meals we pick one up and then me and and
then i start like putting the meal on
the suitcase and start lugging around
and someone goes oh no no no no no no no
don't no don't do that don't do that
that would have been nice yeah i was
like
what's going on and then they they call
another person over and then we have
like a luggage person who puts
luggage on a trolley leads us to the
lift and like they were like oh what
room are you checking into oh okay it's
a room 301 okay that's on the third
floor so they they take us in
um he takes us into the lift presses the
button for us and then takes us out and
he says oh have a have a good stay and
i'm like have a good stay
like what's going on here so we get we
get we get up to the third floor
expecting
like me and cindy to have to take over
from there there's someone waiting for
us on the third floor
like and then they take our luggage out
and leads us to our room and before they
check us in they like once again they
explain everything we can and can't do
all right and so this is this is like
the moan of truth like this is where i
find out
um i find out how big our room is right
and i'm just like i'm preparing for the
worst because i'm just like okay i'm not
going to be able to walk i'm not going
to be able to do anything japan sizes
it's japan this is right uh we
we open the door and it's a [ __ ]
sweet man
it's it's it's a [ __ ] bear in mind
right these hotels are free by the way
it's the government
like this is a hotel i would stay in if
i was on holiday right we walk in
and there's a hallway that leads to our
bed right
and then so we walk in with me and
sydney look at each other and and i'm
just like
the gacha gods are on my side
oh like what is this a trash taste like
why is he getting in the dark and you're
getting the l like like like like the
gacha gods [ __ ] smile down on me we
walk in and like there's a hallway
before we get to our room right and then
we have like a decently sized bed it's
like queen sized bed yeah yeah and then
we have an office uh an office segment
with like a big desk and a massive tv
that both me and sydney can use for
desks to work in if we really wanted to
and
and we were just like
it's gonna be a great holiday sydney
this would be a great [ __ ] holiday i
i've never thought of myself as a
communist
sometimes i i wonder if they have it
right
are humans
i was so pissed off when he messaged me
a picture of his hotel room and i was
like i [ __ ] hate you
i hate you so much yeah because i
remember after i checked in um conor was
just like yo how's the room man it's
[ __ ] isn't it [ __ ] tell me a [ __ ] tell
me a [ __ ] i'm just like i was i was like
please tell me a [ __ ] gum please tell me
about your life right now tell me i'm
not alone he sent me a picture and it
was like it's [ __ ] massive no i
didn't just tell him i didn't just spend
it it's not gonna rain laps in his room
i didn't just send a picture i sent him
like a video a video tour of our room
the fact that i could send like a video
tour of our room right yeah
we live in a society we live in a
society and uh yeah we i mean we had a
lot of the same experiences but i mean
did you have a laundry surface in your
hotel oh [ __ ] no no
no
so so what we were allowed to do so uh
we had we had a receptionist right so
when we walk into the room we notice uh
we noticed we noticed that there's only
one pillow and we're like [ __ ]
what do we do well there's only one
pillow we can't contact anyone so i'm
just like there there's this they gave
us like a hotline in case anyone um
in case anyone like developed symptoms
or anything like that yeah um that you
can phone
but then there's a small print that says
you can phone this this this hotline for
any other requests that you may need
during your stay as well and so
we called them up and uh they were just
like oh
how was your condition and i was like
everything's fine um there's only one
pillow in my room unfortunately and
there's two people staying here can we
get another pillow and they were just
like yeah yeah sure don't worry about it
we'll have someone deliver
we'll have someone deliver a pillow to
you like like normal hotel service and
then so we get another pillow we start
checking in we start looking at the
instructions and then we can see uh we
see that we can order things to our room
like we can order amazon and we're going
to order deliveries
as well they said i could do that but
they had like a very uh weird list of
stuff you weren't allowed to order like
burgers and pizza and chicken
like food certain foods but it wasn't it
was really oddly written that i didn't
really understand it and you couldn't
get certain things like amazon delivered
they said that you couldn't yeah we so
we we actually were able to get amazon
deliveries to our room we couldn't get
overseas we couldn't get hot food that
was like that was like the only thing
that we couldn't get which was hot foods
so we can get amazon deliveries we can
get anything that would help our stay be
more pleasant
um we had like a laundry service where
they would come collect laundry at 7am
and they would like deliver it deliver
it back to our room
we had like a garbage service that would
they would pick up garbage every morning
i had my garbage in my room
we also had a masseuse just like like
yeah they they would like give us new
garbage bags every day
so we could fill it up
and honestly our food aside from like
being cold was pretty damn [ __ ] good
we got like a kind of we got your food
it looked way better than mine yeah we
got like a [ __ ] decent bento every
day i mean this is some this is like
some of this [ __ ] was better than
matsuya you know like
and like how what what was like the
water situation in your place did they
go yeah so so you can ask for more
bottles of water you only got one bottle
of water okay with every meal
and i ran out because i was a thirsty
boy yeah i asked for more and they said
oh sure we'll deliver it they never
delivered it yeah it just didn't turn
out so so so when we went in oh uh so i
i want to say our place also had a mini
fridge as well oh mine did as well did
yours as well okay i think most hotels
just like it just never got cold though
it was like it's just a container yeah
so it made it like less than room
temperature which i was like i guess
that's good but like i mean what am i
going to do come and make them replace
the [ __ ] fridge yes
so like we realized water would be like
a very important resource to [ __ ]
survive as as it is they said you can
use tap water but you know obviously
of you know just like [ __ ] in japan so
it does
um so we go in and there are there is
two bottles of water which is standard i
guess for every hotel stage i didn't
even have that you didn't no okay so
they gave us they started off with two
bottles of water and then we opened the
mini fridge and it was a mini fridge
full of bottles of water [ __ ] off
so
mine wasn't even on i didn't turn it on
so
at the start of our journey we had like
eight bottles of water which was [ __ ]
brilliant and every time they delivered
meals which was like three times a day
yeah um which was like they gave us more
food that then i needed because like by
the time i i had like the breakfast was
massive and by the time lunch was being
delivered yeah i often didn't eat
breakfast because i wasn't hungry yeah
by the way by the time lunch delivered i
was still full from breakfast so i had a
little bit of lunch and then like by the
time dinner came i like i was like [ __ ]
i was eating like a [ __ ] king i don't
know like
it was it was it was a great it was a
great the dichotomy that we faced this
guy's literally living like a [ __ ]
like english king during the plane yeah
this man is a player the peasants are
dying from the black play he's just like
oh there's too much food here guys [ __ ]
me it's like you know you know what i
seen in goodfellas where they go well
the gangsters like go to jail yeah like
they're like having like they're like
champagne and [ __ ] that's basically vlog
that's basically my quarantine hotel
experience it's [ __ ] great i didn't
want to leave honestly like me and
sydney woke up in the like the third day
and we're like oh [ __ ] do we do we have
to go now we have to go back twice can
one of us just get covered
in like two weeks it's so nice
it was it was just a free free vacation
day i didn't have didn't have to pay for
it didn't have to pay for the meals it
was a good meal every day had a
hotel service oh this man living in the
[ __ ] grave
bro i got i got so depressed like on
like the second third day i was
miserable i was so like what was it
called cabin fever that what it is yeah
yeah and like where you were you just i
couldn't even play games or watch [ __ ]
because i was just so like miserable
you're just like lying in bed i was just
like lying there checking twitter and
just like should i do something no i'm
too tired why because i can't [ __ ]
walk so i'm just i'm literally just
lying sitting down all day he's just
and it makes you feel [ __ ] awful like
i don't i don't know it was terrible i
know i'm sound like you're a little
[ __ ] and i'm sure everyone's going to
say that but i mean i like no i i saw
the photos of some of the photos i'd
thought the same way it's one of those
things where when you see it and hear it
you're like doesn't sound too bad but
then when you do it you're like oh [ __ ]
this is really [ __ ] depressing yeah
meanwhile me and sydney were just like
playing games on like the big screen tv
in the living room and i'm just like
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] brilliant i'm like
let's pull out the ps5 we packed it
i didn't have a game console i tried
playing uh some games on my laptop but i
immediately was like oh this is just not
comfortable yeah it's not comfortable
doing this yeah i don't know and the the
smell of my room was so goddamn bad it
was all the food yeah it was like
coagulating in the air yeah and we'll
sweat yeah but then like after reading a
few more posts and after like talking to
various people i think your health your
hotel quality experience is literally
down to chance well yeah because there's
three buses
when i noticed there's three bus lines
and they all take you to a different
hotel and whichever one you go to uh you
get a different experience yeah i think
i think our hotel was not just a
business hotel it was like it was
actually like a four-star hotel yeah and
they put us in which
sounds like it yeah which i'm just like
[ __ ] i got your luck man the lords
are on your side
you know what i will say i know i i this
is kind of this i don't know i don't
make any more squid game jokes but this
was yeah when i got on the bus that we
all came on there was like half the
people on the bus
right which means that half of them got
coveted
[ __ ] hell it was weird first round
elimination
the irish guy was there who i spoke to
and the old man was there
i was like
so i saw that guy without his mask on in
front of like seven armed guards
i was like damn man
what day did you travel on was it a date
what day
oh
what would you mean like was it like a
saturday like a friday and it was all
the same it was all it was it was all it
was because what i will say is that i uh
like i traveled like right i traveled on
like a weekday so like not many people
were traveling so i feel like i was
traveling on a
friday maybe i don't know i mean yeah
friday's like a peak time for people to
travel i'm not sure you know i have to
have a look but yeah it was um because
like if you travel on the weekend i
think more people travel on the weekend
because i feel like
the worst hotels are for the are like
when there are too many people traveling
that it kind of like bleeds out yeah
because yeah i think we'd like there
we didn't have too many buses right
which is why like we i think we had like
one or two buses um and they all went to
the same place yeah so i i feel like
once that hotel started getting filled
out i mean if you think about it why
would you need to drive one and a half
hours for like because we flew in
through hanada which is like south right
yeah there's no reason to drive to a
hotel in the [ __ ] north well they
drove to the hotel and they drove us
back to the airport yeah and then when
you get to the airport you have to have
a
weird specific uh taxi you can't get a
normal taxi yeah can't book a normal
taxi it has to be a quarantine approved
taxi yeah right um and the problem is
that i didn't know what time we were
leaving no so how what time i should
tell this taxi i couldn't figure it out
so i didn't know so i i just i guess now
to wait for two hours at the canada and
but the thing was right is that so this
whole period has just been in quantity
yeah right they drop you off at canada
and they're like [ __ ] off
no no one checks you no one makes sure
and everyone just went went off and i
was like where's everyone going does
everyone know where they're going
i spoke to the irish guy who had um
who'd done it a few times and he was
like yeah you can just like chill around
the airport and wait i'm like well i can
just go to like the cafe and like
interact with people he's like yeah if
you want to and i'm like that doesn't
seem right i didn't i just i stood in
like a corner waiting yeah away from
everyone i was like don't come nearby
i'm sick
but i mean yeah i got it was [ __ ]
weird and it was literally like that
dude who's been in jail life for most of
their life trying to simulate back into
society right i thought they were gonna
name me i'm one of those like
people talking to me that's weird
yeah man it was it was [ __ ] weird and
uh not very fun experience and it got
rid of it now for uk travelers oh really
have they got rid of it have they i
think no no they haven't okay oh they've
just they probably will see they reduced
the quarantine time before we flew
uh i mean before we flew off to england
it was six days in quarantine hotel and
then they got halved two three days
six days in that hotel which is like six
days [ __ ] [ __ ] why couldn't he why
couldn't he be sick he would have been
around
a shiver at that thought another day
there
was nerve wracking because the day i had
to do my test
they called me up and they said hey um
when you get your results if they're
negative you have to leave them right
away
so you have to pack just in case you're
you're
that you're leaving yeah yeah but i
didn't know and because someone on my
plane had been infected
there's a good chance that i could have
got it and uh yeah luckily i didn't but
like they called me up they're like your
test results are native please leave the
room as soon as possible and like
everyone's leaving and i was like what
the [ __ ] i gotta get out of the room
which is weird it was really a [ __ ]
experience don't recommend ign's 10 out
of 10 though yeah i i wouldn't recommend
that experience i would
my experience wasn't that bad oh yeah
you've got a free sweet hotel really
[ __ ] i remember conor like messaging me
every day like i could i knew connor was
like trying to say
i was like trying to drag something
negative about me and i'm just like i
mean am i [ __ ] get gone
tell me about it tell me i was like
honestly it's just it's pretty good
actually i'm i'm having a good time
like you mentioned the next day being
like maybe this this day we'll get to
yeah
i'm sure something bad happens
i went on twitter as well the day i
checked in
and a [ __ ] video from zed the musical
artist
was this [ __ ] had like a
penthouse suite somewhere like literally
a penthouse suite yeah a bedroom
and
an insane view look at this
this is crazy
i'm ready
for the quarantine let's get it and bear
in mind japan isn't even giving out
visas right now to anyone but somehow he
got in you've got to pay us away in
japan in japan and he got a visa to get
in somehow because he's doing a concert
but somehow they made an exception and
people were not happy because there was
tons of people in the comments being
like uh zed you know that like students
haven't been able to enter japan in two
years yeah the [ __ ] and he's off here
showing his suite and zed didn't even
have to do a quarantine for two weeks
only three days
yeah so after the quarantine hotel you
still have to quarantine at home for
about two weeks four four four four
years i'm trying to cancel you for
privilege yeah i was like that's a real
privilege i made a i made a joke because
he gave a room tour that was like two
minutes long of like all the [ __ ]
different rooms he had and all the [ __ ]
he'd been sent he'd been sent like
everything you'd ever need someone
sounded like a gaming pc for his
quarantine and i was like this is
[ __ ] stupid this is the stupidest
[ __ ] i've ever seen
and uh i made a i made a parody video
yeah i was like hey guys here's my room
tour and i just turned the camera and
it's just like the room yeah and that's
the whole room yeah and i was just
joking
i was just joking about like how like
how like the difference compared to
rooms and then people got angry at me
being like you should be happy that you
even were able to enter japan you know
people haven't been able to enter japan
for two years the privilege your show
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
what the [ __ ] that was so annoying this
can't get adopted so i deleted the
tweets i was getting pissed off with the
replies i was like what the [ __ ] are
these reply and they're like why are you
blaming me don't blame me for lip for
being a resident in a country and
getting back in blame the [ __ ]
country for banning any form of visas
what the [ __ ] yeah exactly they feel
like taking it out on me i was like i
was getting so annoyed well i mean those
are humans those people couldn't [ __ ]
tweet to the japanese government right
yeah i was like
they were like you're so lucky that you
can re-enter japan like i'm lucky that i
can re-enter the country i [ __ ] live
in what the [ __ ] do you mean shut the
[ __ ] up
like what this is absurd like don't
don't don't try and say that i'm lucky
that is pretty unfair we're all we're
all unlucky that the government has some
shitty rules on this like don't don't
take it out on each other that's why i
got annoyed about it because
people are attacking other people who
are able to get into the country instead
of i don't know blaming the people who
are making the rules and these arbitrary
rules between countries yeah like in
america right some some states have to
quarantine but others don't yeah and so
there's this whole weird thing where
it's like why i mean it's all one
country right yeah but it's yeah it's
the same in australia as well like most
of the states the like i mean australia
had that the [ __ ] worst though like
victoria i think was locked down for
like 280 days in a row yeah something
like that like no interstate thing like
my sister was like yeah i can't i'm not
allowed to travel more than 10
kilometers from my house yeah otherwise
i get fined but like but like there's
nothing stopping you from just
if you live in like so one of the
countries that was banned was like texas
you could just fly from the state the
state yeah the states the state was
country
wishes uh the state of texas was like
one country that you would have to
quarantine in yeah um go to the hotel
for but there were other states you
didn't have to go to the hotel for how
weird so like why wouldn't you just
drive over to the next state and fly
from there and just say that you've been
there because there's no way they can
validate that they can check that right
so to me it just felt really like
[ __ ] weird that but like covert has
shown that the the rules are not to do
with what's practical it's political
ties and yeah all those things if we've
learned anything and that's what is
shitty is that it sometimes feels like
you're just caught up in some inter uh
international [ __ ] politics of
countries that don't like each other and
countries that do like each other yeah
pretty much favoring i mean the uk did
it a lot too with countries as well
they've been pretty bad for it um it was
just a mess and i hated it and it's [ __ ]
well at least you guys got to you know
sit here with me yeah yeah i mean i mean
i mean like look at us you guys you guys
made it you made it i mean like for the
longest time we were
like literally trapped in this country
because we couldn't fly out for the
longest time
and it's just been it was only recently
that the rules got changed that people
who are already residents can fly out
and then fly back in yeah you know
and i mean now we're just waiting for
the actual you know people who are
waiting on visas because i you know i
can only imagine that that that does
suck you know because like like we were
really lucky to be able to get our visas
before all this happened otherwise we
would have literally trash taste would
have never happened yeah right if we
would had applied for our visas
literally a few months after we got our
visas yeah
we uh we would still be waiting now to
like even get our visas to move to japan
you know it's actually crazy to think
about and japan faced a lot of criticism
when the
when the chronovirus started because
they they banned um
only japanese nationals were allowed
back in yeah right which is like okay i
guess that makes sense but then they
also didn't allow uh green card holders
permanent residents um really yeah so if
you're married if you
uh if you're like me you're british and
you're married to a japanese woman and
then you went and then you came back in
though the my like if i was married to
japanese person they'd be allowed in but
i wouldn't be allowed in oh [ __ ] yeah
i need a few people who that came under
a [ __ ] ton of criticism rightfully so
because if you're because if someone's a
permanent resident of your country
that's literally like where their whole
life is you can't just say like no but
they did and they faced a lot of
criticism which they did eventually
change but they've still been banning
visas and like i feel really [ __ ]
sorry for these these students who had
their life on pause who wanted who had
their whole like basically two years
lined up in japan yeah they've just been
banned from entering japan like they've
been just been waiting yeah and they
haven't
it doesn't make sense to me that they
wouldn't allow some system even if it's
complicated and even if it's [ __ ]
stupid and tedious to get in if you're a
student yeah like i don't understand why
that why they haven't changed the rule
on that it's just japan being japan you
know yeah it's because japan thinks that
like oh the foreigners you're more
likely to get it if you're a foreigner
which is just not true yeah you know
it's just one of those things where you
know you can go through enough
precautions and you can do enough tests
to make sure that like 99 of the time
you'll get it so that it's it's good and
it works but i don't know to me it just
i just i can't fathom it while they're
banned
issuing any visas at all it really
doesn't make sense to me yeah i don't
know it's dumb as [ __ ] yeah and like
after going through that quarantine
experience like i i don't believe any
anyone who's flying in is like spreading
co-fit
people my god they have this [ __ ] on
lock down man yeah honestly um i mean
yeah you need there's like two tests
when you get here and your test before
obviously somehow someone did get
covered on my flight but they were that
was caught and then if you test positive
in the three days you know you have to
yeah i understand it can still slip
through yeah but also it feels like such
diminishing returns at this point
to keep this rule in place you know i
mean it's whatever i'm sure everyone
will have a personal opinion about it
and that stuff i understand allowing
tourists in obviously i get that this is
uh which is which is opening the
floodgates but then there's people who
are like literally waiting on a working
order
it breaks my heart man i really feel
sorry for these people who had their
life lined up to come here and they've
just been just hanging around waiting
really i do feel so sorry for them yeah
yeah it's so [ __ ] it's really [ __ ]
well hopefully soon i mean the the cases
are going down a lot nowadays yeah yeah
i saw an article today that was like
japan's uh drop in covert cases baffles
experts
but also i heard that japan isn't
testing as much so i mean yeah yeah
but i mean it's also because like most
young people now are finally [ __ ]
back yeah
have we missed anything since we've been
gone um i mean the country's opened back
up again i mean in terms of like the the
lock down quite unquote i mean i've
yeah so like
beginning of uh october they were like
oh yeah so uh everything's just good now
yeah oh everything's open you can drink
alcohol if you want everyone's like we
can drink are you are you sure
because you said that last time
yeah we did that last time we could only
do it for a week before you shut that
[ __ ] down again
it was just like the floodgates were
open everyone went out drinking and then
a week later everyone's just like well
that was
that was a good time experts are like
yeah that's a bad idea let's not do that
the japanese government managed to do
something that i think they've never
done before
test the patience of their population
and piss them off yeah i've never seen
people get so actually angry about [ __ ]
yeah which doesn't happen yeah but
people actually got so angry about them
keep extending the lockdown yeah because
they're so [ __ ] wishy-washy as well
they're like they're like oh yeah so uh
the cases are going down it's not zero
but it's going down so maybe we can open
it up again
and then the and then it goes back up
and they're like
well surprised that's a baffle surprise
pikachu
how did this happen it was going down
and the olympics just like blew it over
oh oh god yeah
oh my god just like i watched a video
about all the [ __ ] ups of the olympics
and it was insane yeah having it all in
one video yeah the sheer amount of
people that got fired off the olympic
committee is insane it was like half of
them yeah and then the amount of
controversy the olympic it was insane i
was like this is [ __ ] so [ __ ]
weird oh my god i mean so far it seems
to be going all right um i mean the
other day i was at a at a park
and with some of my friends and someone
was like
we should do a bold gamer move we should
drink a beer in this park and i was like
it felt like it felt like someone just
offered me cocaine i was like no no
that's a good idea i think someone's
watching this this doesn't feel right
i did it it was very liberating but
he [ __ ] the police yeah i was like
[ __ ] the police they can't stop us now
but um yeah i mean i don't know it's i'm
just waiting again for like next week
for the government to be like change
their minds like yeah psych it's it's
locked down again well the real question
is is karaoke open because that's that's
is that everything that's how you know
lockdown's actually ended once the
karaoke opens that's like the equivalent
of like when the british pubs are open
so the karaokes are open uh restaurants
now go past eight o'clock you can order
alcohol basically everything's back to
normal well some of the restaurants are
still clothed
some restaurants yeah it's kind of
confusing now which is basically it's
basically most restaurants because i
actually like phil the day filming this
this is literally my first day out of
quarantine so i i've i've not been out
to explore the town i've uh i've just
been stuck in my you're stuck in my
house oh i sound like andy dufresne
like my first day of
honestly i prefer like the three days of
my quarantine hotel i [ __ ] love my
home i was like oh my god i can work i
have a space i can walk i can walk
around i can i can [ __ ] in a bathroom
that has a bidet that's usable
your your hotel you had a big day but it
was like so weak okay i was like it was
like a duck like tickling my butthole i
wanted something to power wash my cheeks
you know
no like it was okay for like a good like
five six days and then like the second
half of the quarantine it really starts
to get to you where where you're just
you're just in your house and you're you
know seeing everyone out and you're
seeing the country
be normal i guess and you just you just
kind of you just kind of like luckily i
have sydney so i had her to interact
with in case i was feeling too lonely if
i was by myself oh bro i loved it i had
a great time really yeah dude the
dichotomy of man i was like i was
testing like every single ubereats out i
was like i was loving it i my new place
i really love and i got to like kind of
work on it a bit and
i didn't i didn't
schedule anything yeah so i just had
like the full 11 days to just kind of do
what i want i played some games i mean
you did that like three four days oh
yeah yeah i did a 72-hour stream oh yeah
you did that guys i didn't say anything
racist in my sleep that was good i don't
know i muted my mic so maybe i
could but
i saw a lot of mouth flaps
couldn't make it out
and excellent
yeah i uh i did a 70 70 hour stream not
72 because i had a japanese class that i
had to end it so yeah but i did a 70
hour stream which was uh fun yeah i had
a really good time it was kind of last
minute i was kind of like i'm gonna do
a 70-hour stream and my mods were like
what
you're gonna what no you can't do it
it's too soon i was like no we're doing
it we're doing it it's perfect time i'm
gonna do it yeah
yeah i mean you're stuck at home right
now it was good i i i by the third day i
was getting quite tired
um i understand now why ludwig would
watch clips for so long because after a
while i just was like can i stop talking
for a bit like can i just stop i'm
getting really tired
but it was fun it was fun i i sleeping
on stream was not as difficult as i
thought it would be
um i was generally just quite tired from
streaming all day yeah i mean it's it's
i kind of just conked out i tuned in
right at the beginning and then again
right at the end and it was like looking
at two different people i was like wait
is this this time
i was starting to get some like really
big uh like bags under my eyes i could
see that because i i think like i wasn't
sleeping like eight hours because it's
very hard to because yeah when you wake
up you want to check make sure
everything's okay
and uh people uh could have had the
ability to [ __ ] with my lights the whole
time yeah so people were like making my
house a rave while i was sleeping yeah
you know that what's that what's that
[ __ ] that meme edit where it's like
the outside of the house and you can
hear the music inside and the lights oh
yeah it was literally like that
but i just played trash taste episodes
while i slept oh wow that was what i did
easy content right now racking up those
views baby i thought right when i was
sleeping i assumed because when i was
streaming i had about uh 10 to 14k
viewers concurrent yeah which was more
than i normally have i was very
impressed i thought when i was sleeping
it would go down to like okay
there was like 7 000 people watching
this yeah i i i was like i saw that
because i was like what the [ __ ]
what have you been doing because i was
like going through jet lag and i'm like
let's see what connor's up to he's like
seven thousand people watching me sleep
i was like [ __ ] hell man i don't want
7k normally i
my normal streams get like that and i
was like why am i i'm getting more
sleeping what the [ __ ] they're like
sleeping with you like i don't know it
was i know it's like it's like i'm
sleeping next to her you know it was
weird waking up and seeing like people
had subscribed like paid to sub to me
while i was sleeping yeah i'm like right
[ __ ] i should just sleep on stream all
the time i get paid to sleep [ __ ] me
like
i'm kidding it's weird though so i'm
like why did someone give me 50 subs
while i was sleeping it's like 300 quid
more than that i think actually it's a
lot of money i'm like what the [ __ ] the
most generous tooth fairy in the world
yeah yeah right
i was like what the [ __ ]
what is this what's going on
but it was weird and i'd have like weird
moments where i would wake up but i
don't remember waking up and i would see
clips of me waking up and i was like i
don't remember that i don't remember
that i saw a clip of you i don't know if
you were half asleep or not but you just
like flipped off the camera
oh that was halfway through your sleep i
was trying to sleep right and then
people just went ham with my lights all
right and they just started changing it
every second and then i was just like
[ __ ] you guys
um yeah it was fun though i really
enjoyed it i didn't think uh it was
something i ever thought i'd be
interested in but i thought [ __ ] it i'll
try it and uh i obviously had a lot of
fun i'd recommend you guys try it out no
i'm good i'm good man i like i like my
privacy i i can barely stream i can
barely stream as it is people want
people always tell me they're like you
guys should do a trash tasting or you
just take it and turn streaming and then
like i was like oh it could work
something sometimes i mean i i feel like
if if we did it as a group it would be
easier yeah like by myself [ __ ] [ __ ] you
do shifts like we're together sometimes
but then [ __ ] i mean i've done like long
streams with other people yeah you know
that go for like 15 to 20 hours i
couldn't do it by myself i couldn't do
it by myself yeah yeah i don't know i i
i didn't have like many guests come on i
just had uh iron mouse play with me
which was great it's fun when you have
someone else to talk
yeah because that's the thing is like if
you have someone else to bounce off of
right then you don't have to be like so
he was likely talking to china the
reasons why i decided to do it um so i
had not been streaming for like a month
before i left for the uk and so i didn't
stream for a month or all so i didn't
stream for two months and so i have a
second channel as well and we like ran
out of videos we had like no more videos
left and so mood and my editor was like
hey connor please please make like a
[ __ ] ton of content and i was like all
right i got you
so i the 72 hours of the storython i got
like like i don't know like 10 plus
videos out of it so i'm like there you
go
here you go
he was very happy now he's like great
now i have more content to edit this is
great this
yeah is because we have a we have a we
have a deal where we split the money 50
50. yeah so uh yeah that's why he was
desperate he's like i need to get paid
yeah
the channel has been doing great so he's
like come on connor we've got to keep up
the content
because he's like whipping you [ __ ]
he's now the guy who's like come on man
i need content start doing something
connor film it and he's like
and he tells me he's like play this game
it'll be funny for a video yeah all
right okay
he's your content producer now yeah yeah
it's well it's a really good uh it's a
really good um balance because we kind
of started it together because uh
i didn't we were just like okay i won't
pay you for editing fees but you get 50
of whatever it makes and then uh we
thought we'd be in the red for a while
uh or we thought he'd be in there for a
while but luckily yeah it took off and
now it's doing really really well and uh
it's killing it and some of the videos
get like more views than my videos yeah
i saw that one of them got like two
million views now what the [ __ ] should i
put this on my main channel
but yeah they're doing really well it's
uh it's cool it's it's weird yeah i
don't know it's uh i mean we also met
mudan in uh the uk as well yeah
yeah got a call we're gonna catch up
with him uh somehow he found two days
out of his schedule to uh program
himself out of editing and uh we flew
all the way from estonia to come hang
out with us yeah my god my god he is a
machine i i i didn't realize this
i didn't appreciate this until like
actually speaking to him in person
where he is he is insane i've never seen
someone with like a like a more strict
work ethic than he does oh yeah right
that man never quits yeah i'm surprised
he still has like emotion
because like you have to like throw
humanity away to keep up with him he had
his videos in full time speed yeah he
watches the video
i was like how do you i don't think
human brain
i am convinced he's just jacked into the
matrix because how do you edit in four
times speed like you don't do that with
a mouse and keyboard you do that like in
like [ __ ] ghost of the show
basically you like jack yourself in and
like he edits the video in his mind
that's that's all i i'm convinced he's
the one with premiere pro he does
editing speed runs on his on his twitch
channel yeah he edits like my whole of
my videos in like four hours yeah
because because like i remember i
remember talking to him when we were
catching up because he was with us and
like with a bunch of our mates as we
were like all catching up um and i was
talking to him and he was and i was like
oh so you're editing for like trash
taste our specials um off dark connor's
channel conor's second channel and some
of joey's videos and i've heard some of
aki's videos in the past as well and i'm
just like are you close to burnout and
he was like no god i'm looking for more
work do you have more work for me he was
like
what
he said what
he was
he's never disconnected he's never
disconnected and he was like on have you
ever thought about starting a stream
channel i'm like mood on how are you
looking for more work right now he told
that to me as well and he was like he
was like i see you've been uploading
along your second channel uh do you do
you want do you want me to edit those
and i'm like no i'm good
i'm good enjoy your life please
and and and i don't know
i was just like i was just like
flabbergasted that this guy is still
looking for more work after how many
goddamn channels he's already editing
for it's like a content black hole like
it just like keeps ingesting it's never
enough
it's just like open it
i'm just like because i asked i asked
him like we've done what what is what is
your limit have you ever limit tested
yourself and he's like no i want to know
give me more
what is this machine that i'm talking to
man this it's just like he's like tested
like every productivity app out there to
like find which one is like the most
productive yeah so that he knows like
how he can maximize his productivity
he's insane it's just like a different
breed like the it's like a [ __ ] t-100
skynet didn't send back a [ __ ]
terminator they just sent back moody
dude like like edits every video on
earth on youtube and he won't stop until
he like monopolizes the entirety of any
tube basically
i think if every person was like we'd be
we'd be at like intergalactic travel
stages right now like we'd be so
advanced as a society
[Laughter]
like controlling the solar system
jesus christ
i also feel like we'd be very dystopian
but
i don't know though yeah it was fun i
mean it was uh the whole the whole thing
was fun it was really nice getting to
speak to him yeah yeah instead of asking
to do work
ask him to have
just hanging out and just uh like having
a beer with him in person that was that
was very nice this episode is sponsored
by manscaped you know what's spookier
than seeing a black cat on halloween
it's shaving your balls with anything
other than menscape tien that is
terrifying when it comes to below the
waist grooming there's no need to carve
your pumpkins this halloween because
manscaped is here to upgrade your
grooming experience go for a bite-sized
candy bar to a king-sized candy bar and
join the 2 million men worldwide going
to manscape.com and using trash taste
for 20 off plus free shipping look at
this king [ __ ] right here keep the
grooming game going with the performance
package 4.0 inside is the holy grail of
men's grooming items they've made it
easy for you to upgrade your grooming
routine their finely tuned trimmers
feature a cutting-edge stramit blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to
advanced skin safe technology the
lawnmower 4.0 is easily the greatest
ball hair trimmer on the planet and oh
did i mention this the trimmer is also
waterproof too
i know this trimmer is a shower
essential quit trimming like a peasant
today and trim like a king get 20 off
free shipping at manscape.com trash
taste that's 20 off plus free shipping
at manscapes.com
trash taste these nuts
back to the episode
oh
nice
oh
sorry i'm just trying to think what i
did while he goes yeah
what did you do
yeah what'd you do ah [ __ ] what did i do
i saw my family here
first time in two years because like we
all finally got uh vaccinated because we
we all made a rule we were like we're
not gonna see each other until we're all
fully vaccinated because my cousin's
like my younger cousin's only like three
years old or something so i was like
god forbid i didn't want to give him
code right yeah my family so we finally
got vaccinated it's so weird because the
last time i saw my cousin he's five now
and he was like two last time i saw him
so it's just weird i was like
i'm having a conversation with this kid
oh my god yeah it's it's it's so crazy
fast how like kids grow up yeah like
it's just like oh it's a completely
different person we've reached that age
now it is yeah we really like we've and
like i had a lot of uh like friends
living here from since i've known in
like high school in uni who were like i
haven't seen you in a while like you
know now that once the country opens up
we should like catch up yeah oh but i
have to be a weekend because i have to
take care of my two kids i'm just like
have we really gotten to that stage now
i've really gotten to that page because
like
it was just my birthday like about a
week ago um and i was like it's it's
time to get to that point i mean you can
relate god because you're older than me
but like i feel it's around you're a
boomer
thanks for singing me out yeah we're
going you're a bit
but like i feel i don't know at least to
me like around 27 is because i just
turned 27 yeah it's get it starts to get
to the point where it's not so much like
oh yeah it's my birthday it's more like
oh it's my birthday yeah
i've been like that for a while yeah
yeah yeah it's 8 15. yeah it's not like
it's not you know there's no like just
that kind of like childish excitement of
like getting older anymore yeah it
slowly starts to turn into that oh god
i'm getting older yeah stage you know
are you i guess does it happen when you
get 30 is that when that happens um i
don't know like for me that's the only
30 year old
as the only 30 year old here i remember
like it didn't didn't really hit me
until i was uh 29 i guess
and so like ev every every year uh so
every year like we uh we
when when i lived in england we had like
this massive like party where we get to
catch up with all of our friends in
england so we'd like so we have this
party every year yeah um and i remember
it truly hit me because we were at this
party uh and we're there for a few days
so i was having a shower in the morning
and then
i kind of it kind of just hit me that
this is the last time i'm gonna have
this catch up before i'm 30 in my 20s
and then i just had this like full-on
[ __ ] existential crisis in the shower
where like i mean i take long showers i
i i take long showers anyway but like it
was just me
that day that was a long shot
that was like even for me that was a
long [ __ ] shower i think i think
sydney like thought i got kidnapped or
something
like i was just standing there just like
oh my god
like i didn't know how to process that
and it was just i just it was just like
i think i took like an hour-long shower
and then [ __ ] hell well your hands
must have been sponged oh yeah they were
they were the whole body
and then like off that shower which is
completely fine
i was ready for my 30s afterwards um i
also knew that i was like getting to
that point because i uh
me and like a bunch of my friends who
were all vaccinated so safe but uh we we
rented out this like log cabin yeah like
the mountains in chiba and it was like
really nice because you know i hadn't
really had it like a nightlife for about
a month since everything was like closed
down it was like there's no point going
out to like restaurants or anything like
that at night so it's finally nice to
actually you know [ __ ] get out and
yeah change of environment stuff like
that especially with your friends and i
knew i was also getting to that point
because uh all i received was some
pieces of clothing two bottles of wine
and a bottle of whiskey
and i'm like oh i'm getting to the point
where like i see a bottle of whiskey and
i'm like pog champion
just because like after a certain age
you normally have everything you want
yeah right i mean like anything i'd want
is like yeah you want to buy me a
porsche
yeah
it's just like a gift that a mate
doesn't already have it's either like in
in an an acceptable price range it just
doesn't really exist it just gets bigger
and bigger it's either like you buy you
you buy them like a new job or a new car
or a new house well what do you want you
know
[Laughter]
but uh
yeah i mean like i'd say another thing
that happened to me in the uk that
you've just reminded me of is
i i went to the uh went to the tescos to
uh get my bottle of wine then they asked
me how old i was i never get id'd ever
and then
then i was just like oh i'm 20
no wait
i had a moment like that too and someone
asked me how old i was like 23 oh [ __ ]
25.
yeah i legitimately forgot at one point
how old i was turning i was like am i
turning 27 or 28. yeah [ __ ] i don't
remember i had to like do math in my
head to figure out
yeah like i i'd literally like forgotten
that i had turned 30 because like i had
not been asked for id since i turned 30.
yeah and uh so so yeah i i by like
muscle memory i just started saying 20
something and then like i had like this
darren brown moment where i just forgot
the number and i was like resource music
plays
oh no i'm i'm 32. and they were like
we see some id
and i was like oh my god i get to show
my id again oh my god i never get id'd i
wish i got a dude really yeah because i
don't get id here but yeah i've i've
never i've never gotten a goat i've
never got an id'd
in um in japan for some reason i started
getting id'd again when i went back to
the uk i think i think i look older than
you sometimes i think what do you mean
sometimes sometimes sometimes i think
most days i think i think most people
who watch who tune in to trash days for
the first time wait what's the oldest
one everyone thinks that i'm older than
i am yeah which is fair enough yeah just
means and everyone thinks god's like 20.
cause i'm [ __ ] miserable that's right
i'm always complaining i can't wait til
i'm 50. i'm going to complain about
everything it's the beard man it's the
beard no no you have a good beard too
yeah but the thing is if i shave this
off i look 17. well i look like a child
like there's plenty of trash days
episodes where i don't have a beard
right and i i i look at it i'm like whoa
yeah yeah it's just like you shave your
beard instantly you just like lose five
years
like 10 i think i think maybe
like a 12 year old
whereas i feel if god came to a trash
taste recording with a beard like ours
he'd look like a [ __ ] like
i've had like a five o'clock shadow
before and uh yeah i don't know how that
looks
i don't know i just don't like it when
my beard's too long you just throw an
age man just just feels like i feel
something
yeah you could you could kill it or you
could kill it i can kill it maybe i'll
try one day yeah one one one randomly
maybe my mid 30s is
next time we have like like a break when
we don't record trash taste i'll just
let my beard grow out and it'll just be
like
like the dichotomy of like one trash
taste episodes for the for the audience
to be like
what happened during this week
wow you're really aged during this week
didn't it
god just like does some doctor strange
[ __ ]
or some nonsense or something like that
oh my god
i feel like a beard could weirdly suit
you
i know um i i'm just not a big fan of
beards on me personally i don't know
it's i i also like
there's there's this like patch where a
beard like can't grow on my on my chin
as well so i don't know how weird that
would look if i grow it out there's a
bit of patchwork as well around the
place because like the reason the reason
i have this patch is because as a kid uh
when i was a kid i got uh well it's not
that big of an exciting story but my
chin got cut open
uh because i
was on the playground fell on uh hit a
kid fell on the floor and then might
split
oh [ __ ] get my chin open um and so
uh once that got closed up there's just
this patch on my chin that just won't
grow hair so i've always found it like a
sticker just stick something just grab
something just take something we'll just
just grow it out and just like kind of
bumble
yeah break it
bread it into the middle so it just
comes down like that
maybe i'll probably will one day um
i don't know if we should get into anime
i watched an anime
i forgot we're an anime podcast
what did you watch
squid game
yeah i watched
high rise invasion
what the [ __ ] is that exactly what the
[ __ ] is that i watched high-rise
invasion on netflix is that
is that an actual anime i said look it
up the google it's got a japanese
i've never heard of this anime before so
yeah
yeah so so what happened was is that i
was like i was like i told myself i'm
gonna watch the first anime i see on
netflix
why what the [ __ ] is this and i've never
seen this and so i watched it right and
and uh i was pleasantly surprised i
quite enjoyed it really it wasn't it
wasn't amazing but it was it was good
fun
yeah that's and so when i when i when i
started watching it it was the it felt
like the most 6.6 show
it was just good i had a fun time good
fun time it was very interesting and
stupid at times and dumb but interesting
you should guys should uh check it out
should we explain the plot to you please
go go on sure whoa connor explaining
i'll leave it on your heart believe it
or not this is gonna be the most scuffed
plot explanation of
any animation where are you still right
so this main character forgot her name
riley wakes up on the top of a high-rise
building and you you can you can't
go down the stairs of the high-rise you
can only cross like wooden bridges to
get to other high-rise buildings right
right and there's these dudes that are
wearing these masks that are like budget
um anonymous looking masks yes smiley
masks and they're trying to kill you
yeah and they're trying to they're not
trying to kill you they're trying to get
you to jump off the building by making
you have such despair but that goes out
the window within like 10 seconds and
people they're starting to kill you
right so it's one of those things it's
one of those things where they build it
up to be like a really big plot point
they're like they want to make you feel
despair and jump yourself and then
immediately they just come up to you
they're like you jump off paris
these masks people just start killing
everyone and then it was like wait so
that wasn't that wasn't important
but then just people
and then these
masks are like controlling people and
we're trying to find out what's going on
and there's some other
uh they're all issac so it's all all
these characters
all these characters why didn't you say
so earlier
all these characters come from a
different world they wake up on
high-rise buildings and have to go from
different high-rise and there's like
masks that control them and it's kind of
[ __ ] but it's it was it was interesting
enough i had a fun time i i you know
what it was nice watching a show and not
caring if it was going to be good or bad
yeah i enjoyed it and the dub was very
good very good
the dichotomy because i i think like
this was this was the longest stretch
where i went not watching an anime at
all and uh actually picked up a jrpg
that uh i like got [ __ ]
like tales of her eyes yeah is it was it
good it was [ __ ] amazing man why did
you have to say that now i have to get
it it's it's like it's it's the first
time i played a jrpg and like i'm just
like and actually completed it oh no i
like i like i like not only i've not
only completed it i think i'm like close
to 100
as well my god like it's the only
[ __ ] jrpg where i i cared about it so
much and i didn't want the journey to
end that i
100 100 percented the [ __ ] fishing
mini game okay i caught that that's how
you know i caught every fish in this
game so i could see every skit that
there was available
in the game okay
how many hours have you put in this game
uh at the moment about 80 hours
so like for jrpg length that's actually
that's not too bad that's not too bad
it's like especially for a hundred
percent run that's nice that's pretty
short
in like the past two weeks right yeah
i mean what else was he going to do
in quarantine man
no but it's it's uh i mean like one
thing that really surprised me is that
it really got me to care about
game mechanics i'm just like i'm i'm
here for the story and characters yeah
and then i just got really absolutely
fans found out that games games can be
good
and then i just got really absorbed into
the combat system of this game and i'm
just like how did you trick my how did
you trick my non-gamer brain into caring
about this [ __ ] right because because
like i've played so many tales games and
the reason i got it and tales was
because it had like a real-time combat
system yeah and that was i played uh
brazilia and i didn't like
yeah and that was in the time where i
only really got into
tails games because
every other jrpg was turned back com
turn-based combat with random encounters
and tails was like no no no no how about
you have a real-time battle system with
enemies that you can see when you get
into a battle right and then that kind
of like as time gone on that became more
normalized in a lot of jrpgs like you
know you see the modern final fantasy
and it's basically just an it's an
action rpg with some turn-based systems
implemented into it and so for the
longest time i still play tails games
but they weren't they didn't grab me as
much as say back in the old school days
where this was the only type of jrpg
there was that had this type of system
and so i i like my love for the channel
series had like waned a bit
so when i got tales of a rise i only got
it because people were just like yeah
it's a new tales game and i'm like i'm a
tales fan maybe i'll just play this like
yeah i'm i'm a tales fan
i'm gonna ignore that for a second i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm glad you said it
before i did
i just kept saying tales and i just kept
thinking i was in my head i was i was
just imagining [ __ ]
so like i'm a big tales
like if i wasn't in quarantine i
wouldn't have played it and then on the
first day i just like i played it for
like a good 10 hours and i was like oh
no
oh no i'm invested
if there's one thing you don't want to
be invested in it's the jrpg because you
just have to basically write off like
two three weeks of your life
if that happens pretty much and it was
like it's been such a long time where
you know
you know like when you're so absorbed
into a game that every waking moment
you're not playing the game you you're
either playing the game or you're
thinking about playing the game i missed
that feeling yeah yeah and it was
[ __ ] great and uh the combat system
in this is like closer to something like
devil may cry than it is like previously
like you can you can you can do like
[ __ ] ridiculous amounts of combos in
this game right can i kind of can i go
for the game mechanics do you care about
the game mechanics at all um sure i mean
it's better than you talking about aero
game
i'd love to hear how you like it okay so
most tales games that i played before
it's just like [ __ ] button mashing
like you press yeah that's what i didn't
like about it yeah the last time i
played it yeah and you can get through a
lot of this game through just button
mashing and then like it there's there's
this really weird difficulty curve where
the later part parts of the game you
like before in every tails games you can
just get away with like tapping one
button tapping special attack anything
like that but then they've built they've
layered so many different systems onto
this combat system from like previous
tales games that you can you you realize
you can just start layering [ __ ] over
like things over things everything's
everything so they introduce you to you
like you already have you can only do a
certain amount of moves for before your
character goes back into a rest state
right so you can you can only do like
three basic attacks and enough
enough basic enough special attacks
before your meter runs dry but then if
you juggle the enemy you add more basic
attacks on on top of that right and then
on top of that you have
group you have group attacks as well
where people in your party can also join
in on an attack and then what i didn't
realize is that tails added this system
where you can switch to another person
mid like like mid battle so you don't
have to pause the game to switch to
another character you can literally it's
the top of one button you can switch to
another person so you base you can
basically chain combos end combo with
one person then switch to like do a
special attack with another person
switch to that person
and so the system awards
awards people who are able to change
really good combos because if you get
your combo meter long enough then you
can do basically a finishing attack yeah
right it looked kind of like genting a
little bit yeah that's that's the thing
it's basically like it did it was a lot
like engine except having except not
having just one person but having four
people yeah
that your chain when you're playing
against him from how much yeah that
you've changed
yeah but there's a lot it's like way
more in depth than genji i would say it
is it does have
some similarities to the gentian combat
system but it's like way more in-depth
and you can
get combos that are like way longer than
genji you get like 100 hit combos
sometimes the only thing that i found
really funny and
i don't know if this is the whole game
but i was watching someone stream it on
twitch and they were fighting this
dragon
and during this fight every single
character was saying their voice lines
at every single point yeah and i was
like what the [ __ ] is this i can't hear
anything everyone is just screaming in
their own attacks yeah is that that
happening all the time
yeah pretty much that's pretty standard
for a job but i couldn't hear anything i
couldn't hear what anyone was saying
because everyone was shouting their
attacks i was like what is this i mean
it's the same with like uh like
xenoblade as well right like when you
when you're fighting that [ __ ] i can't
watch because that's
it xenoblade annoys me watching
xenoblade because i'm just hearing
everything
yeah
at the same time
[ __ ]
do you know you like that no i can't
because i can't hear what everyone's
saying it's just noise you don't have to
hear what they're saying i i i can't if
i wanted to i can't hear it it's not
it's not like they're giving like
important information i just wish that
it was like i don't know when i was
watching as a i don't know from a
viewing experience it was very annoying
at least right from a gaming news
probably he didn't give a [ __ ]
i think i think if you're i think if
you're watching it yeah as a viewer it
might get a little bit annoying because
that's the only thing you're focusing on
yeah but again it's not like they're
gonna be like they're gonna drop like
huge narrative plot points as they're
going
i'm your dad
i know i was just like this is too loud
shut up
because like on top of that as well
sometimes uh sometimes the characters
will have conversations
as they're screaming as they're
screaming their attacks
i mean there's there is a lot of things
going on i love that i love that about
tales yeah this kind of campaign that's
that's the anime side that i live for
you know yeah there's something super
campy about it that i love it it's like
one person is like being like hey that
was a good shot and the other one's like
ah
he's like all right you're not listening
sounds pretty cool though
like a little better uh combat system
than before yeah
i don't i don't trust people who prefer
um turn-based combat over that i'm just
like what's wrong with you who hurt you
i mean
[Laughter]
i didn't say anything
except for persona we haven't figured
out a way to make it fun so we keep
using the same shitty thing because we
know it sort of works but like no one's
like
right yeah
i don't like turn-based combat i don't
know i'm just used to it so much to the
point where i like but that's the thing
though i think that's that's that's why
people i get it if you didn't grow up
with it it's [ __ ] annoying yeah and i
i think it's just because it's one of
the it's a thing that we haven't figured
out a better way and i still feel that
some games the whole real-time combat in
the way it's still kind of jank at times
yeah it sounds like it's it's good it's
really good like they finally figured it
out a little bit yeah it's it's really
good because because they teach you the
basics and then they don't teach you all
these like more advanced techniques that
you can do to like basically extend your
extend your combos and like make
flashier moves but they give you
gameplay incentives like i said like if
you get a combo for long enough without
stopping it
then you can do a finishing move on an
enemy and like when the when the high
health it's harder than when they're low
health so the common meter builds up
faster when they're low health so like
when when you sometimes you start off a
battle
and depending on how well you can get
your combo off because when when you
kill one enemy with a finishing move
that makes it easier to do the next
enemy and the next enemy it's kind of
like a domino effect right so you can
you can depending on your the difficulty
if you start off a battle well you can
clear the enemy so fast or you'll you
can like get ko'd really easily
depending on like how well you start off
your how are you starting for your
attacks on your combos which is just
which is just something that i never
experienced before in a tales game
because tails was always i'm playing
because i like it and it's anime and
it's jr
and then the combat the combats here
just is just to
like forget making me forget about the
fact that i just hate grinding and
combats and like yeah i don't like
writing and turn-based battles but this
one was just it it's legit good game
it's
i can see why
it's like the closest thing tails has
got to like a mainstream release
because it is a legitimate game that i
think a lot of people who don't even
like jrpgs
would like um
so yeah
i've been tempted ever since they
announced that i'm just like i can't do
it to myself do it i have so many
[ __ ] jrpgs lined up that i still need
to play i still haven't played the
[ __ ] like uh near replicant i was
like the wrong place i bought that on
steam and it's just been sitting there
i'll get
i'll get to it eventually and then
they're like okay there's five more
jrpgs i bought sega uh bass fish not
bass bass [ __ ]
it's like a bass fishing and i never
bought it i never
oh
the sega genesis why
why not god
because
fishing i think we should do a trash
taste special we do high score on sega
fishing
bass
fishing
look at that game look at that can we
just go real fishing i'd rather go i'd
rather just go real fishy and then play
i also really want to play the new
[ __ ] nickelodeon fighting game
they actually made it into like a
serious like fighter yeah yeah and
apparently someone's already figured out
that some characters are just [ __ ] of
course
we're gonna be getting patch notes for
days and tier lists yeah spongebob is
asked here patrick is detailed spongebob
bottom two behind bottom tiers
oh my god
did you also hear the news just
yesterday
i know you're going to see what of sora
getting uh confirmed for smash bros oh
yeah and the internet just
breaking i've never seen the internet
break yeah i mean that's hard i'm happy
for those fans who like sora i was room
for
massachusetts broke down crying as if
like she lost a family member like does
nikki play smash
she does oh okay but i didn't know
she played because she never played with
me yeah right but apparently she's
played like the 3ds variant and stuff
like like like the older yeah but now
there's i know there's going to be just
like a whole like
of new smash players
yeah i mean i i you know i don't it's
one of those things where i'm not happy
for those fans who got it but i don't
really care i yeah
i mean i i never
[Laughter]
i mean i was hyped just purely on the
base of like
just thinking to myself how the [ __ ]
like they must have thought for tooth
and nail with disney to get that maybe i
think i think i think maybe smash is big
enough where they would have been like
this oh yeah i'm sure like sakurai's
done enough now where he's just like
do you know who i am i mean i mean
releasing uh kingdom hearts on the
switch yes
which is probably one of the biggest
reasons why yeah i mean like i was more
surprised about minecraft steve yeah
that did break twitter yeah yeah that
broke twitter as well yeah because
because like sora i was just as as
someone who's not that invested in smash
or kingdom hearts i was like i see it
it's like because it wasn't that big of
a surprise for me where i was just like
what the [ __ ] where did this come from
it was just like yeah i mean they had a
cloud on there they had uh
see this is why i want a master chief
man it would have been so out of left
field yeah master chief would have been
bro
right the [ __ ] announcement comes you
hit the [ __ ] halo music bro that
would have
been like this is full for memes this is
i do not actually want i do not care if
he is in it or not but i just want the
meme potential that's what people were
saying about sans until they added yeah
yeah yeah i just want i just want
masturbation i added a doom guy though
as a skin no yeah
one of one of those skins is dude it's
your skin though come on man i could
have been in it yeah no damn guy could
have been
we better get the master chief well i
mean you know nickelodeon did a fighting
game so who knows like no no i don't
know what i want what is this
nickelodeon fight against [ __ ] it's
basically
they took nickelodeon all the
nickelodeon characters and turned into a
spell it's like actually like
like a well-designed game yeah i've
heard okay i don't know i don't really
care i saw a video of some guy just
saying how broken spongebob was and
um and i never thought i'd see the word
spongebob needs to get nerfed
written in text by like i saw and i was
like wow what a time to be alive
oh man
i don't know like like i'm super happy
like i personally have never really like
sat down playing kingdom hearts game
like i only know so much about it
because i live with a kingdom hearts fan
but like i'm happy for the kingdom
hearts fans i just know that every time
you talk to a kingdom hearts fan they
try to explain the story i'm just glad i
don't know yeah i mean it's like the you
know it's it's it's like as a fake fan
it's just like i understand how it feels
getting they just love it
they [ __ ] love it it's whatever they
they can have i'm glad they have
something i wish i i wish i had
something that i got there i probably
know more about the kingdom hearts lore
just purely because of aki yeah because
i had to sit down and watch her play all
of kingdoms 3 and every turning point i
was like uh may i ask a question
several questions yeah i love the memes
of like mickey mouse wearing like a
black hood i don't understand yeah i
don't understand the context yeah
that's king mickey but like yeah but
like mickey mouse is wearing a black
hood and i'm like all right
i should just like and he gets into the
darkness and he fights enemies i don't
know this is totally unrelated but it's
just reminding me of this the perhaps of
the rapper memes with the
daffy duck have you seen that one i
think so yeah yes i slammed my penis in
the car door memes have you seen
something else
it's really weird when you just say that
i spoke to emily and
we were all like do you have you guys
seen the the daffy duck uh yeah daffy
duck where he slams his penis in the car
door with parappa the rapper
and we were like yes we love that meme i
was like yes
it's such a dumb meme i'll show you it
later all right
it's very weird when you just say that
when i hear that out of context
it's one of those memes that passed very
fast but i found it so funny and i i
realized i'm such a child that's sad
it's so funny
you're like crying
there's something in my eye
it's just so funny
just the memory of this meme it's just
breaking this matter
[Applause]
i just had to talk about i don't know it
reminded me of the i don't know
yeah that's i just love though like when
like again like i'm not too invested in
smash anymore but every time they
announce a new character i'm like okay i
always like try and keep up to date with
what the community says
how it feels to like like the nba and
like have the draft yeah yeah it's like
just like all of the all of the
predictions i see from smash fans it's
just [ __ ] hilarious because with this
lost control you can bet on the
characters with this last drop yeah like
some of the like there was three main uh
like you know predictions it was like
sora obviously yeah master chief
obviously third one was [ __ ] goku oh
and crash bandicoot it's not like i saw
it yeah crash bandicoot but like go
there was like an alarming amount of
people who were like
goku no confirm
i'd be hyped for goku
and i'm like i'd be hype but
i just can't imagine a game where goku
beats up mario
and sonic and sonic it just sounds
kidding me weird that sounds amazing it
sounds amazing what's that what's up i
don't get hype over there what's that
game where you bet on uh characters that
fight um like salty bets is that what it
is that's it that's right
it turns into salty it just tastes like
salty yeah yeah yeah
it just it just turns it
was just like decades ahead of his time
hanson was fighting alucard
for sure
and then like
back from one hp and destroys allentown
you're like that checks out that sounds
good
oh my lord yeah well that's been fun
yeah it has been fun fun it's nice being
back it's good i'm i'm i'm just happy
that i get to see you guys again every
week yeah
a while guys it's been a while
look at look at these lovely people who
wonderful people yeah we've stuck around
for them exactly for the one week yeah
many weeks
for the one week between the last year
or so but hey if you like support the
show then consider supporting us on
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us your means on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify i haven't said
that in six weeks i know
and i said it flawlessly it's like
ingrained in here man it really is
it is genuinely good to be back i was
like this is my first day out quarantine
and most people you know when they've
been stuck inside for like
two weeks they wouldn't be excited to go
back to work but i'm like i was like
genuinely excited to go back to the
office man
hell yeah i get to see my boys again
let's go to the office hell yeah i'm
excited all right well i guess uh
nothing else to say right we'll see you
guys next week continuing it's normal
yeah bye guys
[Music]
you